GO RIGHT INTO THE PREAMBLE OKAY
SO READY TO GO. HE. ALL RIGHT
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS IS GONNA COME TO
ORDER- GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME-
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVER
NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE ARE GOING TO LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
HOLIER COMMITTEE HEARING HERE
IN THE CAPITAL AND THERE IS NO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY TODAY TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. I WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND ALL IN OUNCES NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-692-8953 I'LL SAY THAT ONE
MORE TIME. 877-692-8953 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN ZERO FIVE.
SIX NINE ZERO NINE AGAIN THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN ZERO FIVE
SIX NINE ZERO NINE FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES THAT WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND-
COMMITTEE WEBSITES. WHEN WE
MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION. PRESAS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THEIR WAY MAYBE A SHORT
WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE ON MUTE IT AND YOU WILL
BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING HEARING
ON PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY
OVER THE PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PATIENCE ALL MAINTAIN DECORUM
AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
COMMUNICATIONS MUTED. IT'S ALSO
A GOOD TIME TO REMIND EVERYONE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY THAT THIS
IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE SO PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO THE
FISCAL ASPECTS OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON AND PLEASE
REFRAIN FROM REPEATING PRIOR
TESTIMONY. WHILE EVERY EFFORT
HAS BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND A CONDUCTOR
HEARINGS AND IS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS ARE ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL. PATIENTTO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES. WE HAVE
FIFTY SEVEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA FIVE OF WHICH ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR DO PASSED MOTION.
THE REST OF THE BILLS ARE ALL
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. FOR
ANYONE LISTENING WHO IS
INTERESTED IN AB EIGHT OH THREE
BY BONNER **** BATH. THAT BILL
HAS BEEN RESCHEDULED FOR NEXT
MEETING. WE'RE ALSO GOING TO BE
TAKING AB EIGHT NINETY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SERVE ON DAYS.
OUT OF ORDER AS A COURTESY. AND
THAT MEASURE WILL BE OUR FIRST
UP TODAY SO AGAIN IF YOU'RE
HERE FOR AB EIGHT NINETY. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE THAT BILL FIRST-
I BELIEVE NOW. WE HAVE A QUORUM
YEAH. AND SO- MISTER CONSULTANT
WOULD YOU CALL THE ROLL FOR THE
PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING A CORE.
CENTER PORTANTINO. I'M HERE-
PORTANTINO HERE SENATOR BATES
BATES HERE BRADFORD. JONES
SAWYER JONES HERE KAMLAGER
AIRED BY CASKEY CASKEY HERE FOR
MEMBERS WE HAVE FOR MEMBERS TO
THE CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF THE HEARING
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS
INCLUDING FOR RECALLS I'M GONNA
BE INSTITUTING A TIME LIMIT ON
WITNESS TESTIMONY EACH SIDE
WILL BE PERMITTED THREE MINUTES
OF TOTAL TIME FOR PRIMARY
TESTIMONY ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY OWN MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE IF NECESSARY WE WILL
ALSO LIMITED EDITION OF
TESTIMONY TO TWELVE MINUTES
EACH FOR EACH SIDE. AS A
REMINDER ALL WITNESSES SHOULD
LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY TO THE
FISCAL ASPECTS OF THE BILL I
WILL STRICTLY ENFORCE THE ME
TOO PORTION OF THIS WHICH IS
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION. WITH THAT WE ARE
GOING TO GO RIGHT INTO AB EIGHT
NINETY FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES ON PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS. THIS IS. A
DO PASS AND SO. PLEASE PRESENT
YOUR BILL GIVE US A
PRESENTATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT NINETY WHICH WILL ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY AND PROMOTE THE
INCLUSION OF WOMEN IN BY PARK
MONEY MANAGERS AND THE ASSET
MANAGER. MANAGEMENT INDUSTRY
TODAY ONLY 1% OF VENTURE
CAPITAL BACKED OUT FOUNDERS ARE
BLACK AND LESS THAN 2% ARE OF
LOT AND ACTS OF DISSENT. IN A
COUNTRY WHERE WOMEN MAKE UP A
MAJORITY OF THE POPULATION
WOMEN RECEIVE A DISMAL TWO
POINT 7% OF VENTURE CAPITAL
FUNDING WHAT WOMEN OF COLOR
RECEIVE LESS THAN 1% OF VENTURE
CAPITAL FUNDING. AS THE SAYING
GOES IF YOU CAN'T MEASURE IT
YOU CAN'T MANAGE IT AB EIGHT
NINETY IS AN ATTEMPT TO DO JUST
THAT. OBTAIN DATA IN THERE WE
NEED TO MEASURE HOW THE FUNDS
APPROACH DIVERSITY THE ANALYSIS
BY THIS COMMITTEES COMMITTEE
STATES IT'S BELIEVES THAT
CALPERS CAN ACCOMMODATE. THE
WORKLOAD IMPOSED BY THIS BILL
WITH EXISTING RESOURCES WELL
CAL STIRS CAN DO SO WITH
MINIMAL PERSONAL COSTS
INCREASES WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY BRIEFLY. AS A SPONSOR
OF THE BILL SELANDER BROOKS OF
THE NEW AMERICAN ALLIANCE AS
WELL AS JIM PARK CEO OF THE
ASSOCIATION. OF ASIAN AMERICAN
INVESTMENT MANAGERS. ALL RIGHT
WE WILL- THERE ON THE PHONE
LINE. FOR THE HEARING PERSON.
ON THE PHONE AND I WALKED TO
THE MATH. HAVE A TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES. HOME DEPOT. IF YOU ARE
ON THE PHONE LINES AS A WITNESS
YOU SHOULD BE OPEN AT THIS
POINT YEAH I DON'T KNOW IF THEY
PRE ARRANGED IT SO WILL SEARCH
FOR THEM AND GIVE THEM A SHOT.
AND CHECK WHAT WAS THE NAME
AGAIN. WE HAVE SO LAUNCH BROOKS
AS WELL AS JIM PARK. I DO NOT
SEE EITHER ONE OF THOSE. I'M L.
WITNESSES ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO
TO SEE IF THERE'S A DISLIKE
INSTITUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
AND SEE IF THEY'RE ON AS A
PARTICIPANT. ARE THEY I MEAN I
GUESS THOSE INSTRUCTIONS AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT SINCE
THEY'RE NOT THERE WILL GO TO
OTHER WITNESSES THERE'S NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM. THERE'S NO ONE
AROUND TWENTY FORTY. BOB OR OR
OFFICES SUPPORT. MODOC THIS IS
SUPPORTERS NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY- MODERATOR WOULD YOU
QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE WHO WISHES TO SUPPORT AB
EIGHT NINETY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR AB EIGHT NINETY
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME NOW IN
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATE IS GOING TO
GO AHEAD GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
OFFLINE AND THEN PLACE IT BACK
INTO THE QUEUE. AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR AB EIGHT NINE ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO THANK YOU ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIR. EVERYBODY ELSE
GOING TO GET ONE ZERO SO AN
OPERATOR CAN GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
FORTY EIGHT. YOU ARE OPEN.
THANK YOU A GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF MY TEAM
IS A LARGE FERNANDES BROOKS I'M
THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
THE NEW AMERICA LIONS. CLUB THE
NUMERIC ALLIANCES THE NATIONAL
HISPANIC NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
WITH A MISSION TO PROMOTE.
TRANSPARENCY DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION PARTICULARLY IN THE
FINANCIAL SERVICES INDUSTRY.
LEADERSHIP AND MEMBERS LEVERAGE
THEIR INFLUENCE TO INCREASE
CAPITAL ACTION FOR WOMEN AND
MINORITY OWNED FIRMS INTO A
CALORIE DIVERSE LEADERSHIP AND
ENTREPRENEURSHIP EDUCATION
CORPORATE AMERICA AND PUBLIC
SERVICE WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND THE FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR AB EIGHT NINE ZERO
THANK YOU AND WE WILL ALIGN
FIFTY ONE. FIFTY ONE LOOKS LIKE
YOU TOOK YOURSELF AUDI Q. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO. REACH YOU AT ONE
ZERO. ARE YOU BACK ONE FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
JIM PARK- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY
MY NAME IS JIM PARK THE CEO OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF ASIAN
AMERICAN INVESTMENT MANAGERS.
THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE THAT WILL REINSTATE AND
ENHANCE TRANSPARENCY AND HOW
CALPERS AND CAL STIRS THE POOR
THE RESPECTIVE INVESTMENT
ASSETS. NOT A NEW REQUIREMENT
FOR THE STATE PENSION FUNDS BUT
LARGELY A REINSTATEMENT OF
SOMETHING THAT WAS IN CHRIST
PREVIOUSLY. AIM IS A NATIONAL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION FOUNDED
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX DEDICATED
TO PROMOTING DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION OF ASIAN AMERICANS
PACIFIC ISLANDERS AND OTHER
UNDER REPRESENTED POPULATIONS
IN THE FIELD INVESTMENT
MANAGERS. AB EIGHT NINETY IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP IN
PROVIDING POLICYMAKERS WITH THE
DATA THEY NEED TO UNDERSTAND
HOW THE BILL'S ALLOCATION
DECISIONS ARE MADE. AND HOW
THOSE THINGS CARE ENHANCE ALIVE
ALL COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO SPEAK ON THIS IMPORTANT
MATTER TRACK. OUR WE'VE HEARD
FROM TWO PRIME WITNESS- AND
THEY RESPECTED OUR TIME
ALLOTMENT WE WILL GO NOW TO ME
TO USE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO JUST SAY YOUR NAME
YOUR FILIATION IN YOUR POSITION
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT NINETY.
GET ON THE PHONE LINES SO- I.
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT FOR A BI
EIGHT NINETY PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSE I SEE ONE PERSON
COMING TO THE MICROPHONE COME
ON SIR. TELL US YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MARK GRAHAM I
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WITH
THE ORGANIZATION NAME IT IS
CALIFORNIANS WHO APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY MORE OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
I SEE ANOTHER GENTLEMAN COMING
UP. YES MY NAME IS PAUL MCGAVIN
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE MY
ORGANIZATION NAME IS
CALIFORNIANS WHO SUPPORT THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BEING
WILLING TO HEAR ALL BILLS THAT
HAVE SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE IN
THEIR BILL FILES PROVING THEY
WOULD HAVE SIGNIFICANT FISCAL
IMPACTS ON CITIES COUNTIES AND
THE STATE WE OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ALL RIGHTS
SEE NO ONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM
ANYONE A ROOM TWENTY FORTY HE'S
SAYING NO AND THEIR MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB. EIGHT NINETY. AGAIN
TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR AB EIGHT
NINETY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE ZERO TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR AB. EIGHT NINE
ZERO. AND THAT MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
LET'S MOVE TO THE PARTMINER
FINANCE. AMAZON A DAY THE BILL
OUT OF YOUR CHAIR NUMBERS JOLIE
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
CAL STIRS IN CALPERS AT THIS
BILL IMPOSES MINORS OR WILL
COST AND WE CAN CURRENT
ESTIMATE. ALL RIGHT WE'VE HEARD
FROM FINANCE MY COLLEAGUES THIS
YOU HAVE A QUESTION MISTER WHAT
KOWSKI WAS REMOVED THE BILL WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL C.
MISTER BRADFORD AS A QUESTION
NICE SERVER STEVEN I JUST WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
CERVANTES FOR THIS COMMON SENSE
MEASURE AND THAT. TO SPACE THAT
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON SINCE I'VE
BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE IN OVER
TWENTY YEARS BEFORE GETTING
HERE UPPLIER DIVERSITY IS
IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY IN ASSET
MANAGEMENT THAT IS DEVOID OF
BOTH WOMEN AND MINORITIES IN
THE SPACE SO I COMMEND YOU FOR
DOING THIS. OUR DIVERSITY IS
OUR STRENGTH AND IT MAKES NO
SENSE THAT THESE INDUSTRIES
CONTINUE TO BE WHITE MALE
DOMINATED AND I THE EVEN
INSURANCE INDUSTRY UNDER.
DIRECT A LOT OF- COMMISSIONER
LAWLER IS EVEN LOOKING AT
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY AND HOW THEY
DO THEIR. BUSINESS AS WELL SO I
COMMEND YOU FOR THIS. ALL RIGHT
TO THE MISTER ROGERS WOULD YOU
LIKE CLOSE. YES YOU MISTER
CHAIR AGAIN THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE WITH
MUCH NEEDED INFORMATION ABOUT
THE ON GOING IN EQUITIES IN THE
CAPITAL FUNDING SPACE AN AXE
ACCESS TO CAPITAL. WELL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAVE A MOTION MISTER. CHIEF
CONSULT WOULD YOU CALL THE ROLL.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT NINETY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES.
IT'S NO BRADFORD BRADFORD FIVE
JONES JONES NO KAMLAGER HI I'M
LONGER FIVE LAYERED. MARC OWSKI
HI CASKEY FIVE FOUR ROADS BILL
IS FOUR OH TWO WE HAVE
EVERYBODY OUR MAKE WE'RE GOING
TO CALL THE ROLL OPEN FOR. MR
LAYERED MISTER GRAY LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE TRYING TO COME IN EARLY
OUT OF ORDER. SINCE I'M IN A
GOOD MOOD AND IT IS GET AWAY
DAY I WILL ACCOMMODATE YOUR
PRESENCE. PLEASE COME UP AND
TELL US ABOUT A. B. SEVEN
EIGHTY THREE ON SURFACE MINES
SURFACE SAFETY REGULATIONS SO
FOR THE RECORD EVERYONE. THIS
IS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
THAT IS SCHEDULED LATER IN THE
DAY BUT WE ARE GOING TO
ACCOMMODATE. THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND SO PLEASE TELL US
BRIEFLY ABOUT AB SEVEN EIGHTY
THREE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I'D LIKE SO MANY OF MY
ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUES I. ALL YOUR
SCHEDULES IN HIGH REGARDS HERE
EARLY AND NOT PREPARED TO MOVE
THIS COMMITTEE ALONG THIS BILL
SIMPLY IMPROVES THE WORKPLACE
SAFETY CONDITIONS OF SURFACE
MINING OPERATIONS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
I HAVE. CALCIUM HERE TODAY TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE AND HOPEFULLY
SEVERAL ORGANIZATIONS INTRA
INTERESTED IN TRANSPARENCY WILL
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A BILL
THANK YOU ENSURE YOU'RE
STIPULATING THAT YOU HOLD THE
SENATE IN HIGH REGARD. I
CERTAINLY DO I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THAT'S CLEAR. THANK
YOU- SO NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
JUST TECHNICAL SUPPORT. THAT'S
ALL RIGHT SO I SEE NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM WILL OPEN UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM-
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR- WE'VE SWITCHED
GEARS OF THIS IS AB SEVEN
EIGHTY THREE. IS THERE ANYONE
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN EIGHTY
THREE ON THE PHONE LINE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FOR AB SEVEN EIGHT
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
TWO TESTS FIND SUPPORT FOR A BI
SEVEN EIGHTY THREE. AND WE WILL
BEGIN WHAT FIND EIGHTY ONE YOU
WERE IN QUEUE YOU TOOK YOURSELF
OUT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO REPRISE. ONE
FINAL REMINDER TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FOR A BI SEVEN EIGHT
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. POINT EIGHTY ONE YOU
ARE OPEN. JERRY JOHNSON RUNNING
CONSTRUCTION COMPANY TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT. AND NEXT WE WILL GO
TO. FINE SEVENTY SEVEN ZERO
POINT SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD HI THIS IS CHARLIE RAY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION AND INDUSTRIAL
MATERIALS ASSOCIATION AND WE'RE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. HI MISTER
CHAIR THERE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW GO
TO OPPOSITE FOR AB SEVEN EIGHTY
THREE IS THERE ANYONE IN THIS
ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY. IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN EIGHTY
THREE SIR PLEASE COME UP AND
TELL US YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND I HOPE IT'S
GOT A CREATIVE NAME. AND YOUR
POSITION. BOB YES MISTER
CHAIRMAN MARK GRAHAM. ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIANS WHO DISTRIBUTED
A COPY OF THIS TO EVERY
LEGISLATORS OFFICE ON TUESDAY.
WE ALSO HOLD THE SENATE IN VERY
HIGH REGARD AND WE'RE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE ANOTHER
PERSON OPPOSED. I THINK HE SAID.
HEY GUYS GET SICK CLOSER I WILL
TRY. MY NAME'S PALMER KEVIN AND
I WOULD CALIFORNIA'S WHO
ENCOURAGED THE SENATORS AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS TO CALL DR
TOMAS ARAGON TO DISCUSS HOW
WIRELESS BROADBAND HAS CREATED
CONDITIONS OF CHILD
ENDANGERMENT IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND SACRAMENTO AND WE OPPOSE
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT MOVING ON
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO AB SEVEN EIGHTY
THREE BY THE ESTEEMED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MISTER GRAY. EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FILED BY
ZERO. TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
AB. SEVEN EIGHT THREE. NOBODY
IS QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS ESTIMATES
THE PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL
WILL COST NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH FUND ANNUALLY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'VE HEARD
FROM SUPPORT OPPOSITION IN
FINANCE. YOU HAVE A QUESTION
YOU WANT TO MAKE A MOTION. YES
THEY HAVE A BAD TIME I LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL SO THE MOVE THE
MONTH BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO ME CENTER
CALM WATER. MISTER GRAY WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YOU HAVE A
COMMENT MISTER I JUST I WON'T
BE SUPPORTING THE MOTION AND
IT'S- IT'S NOT ON FISCAL
GROUNDS IT'S ON OTHERS BUT WANT
TO MAKE IT CLEAR DR. BUILT
CHECKED INTO THE NINETY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IT'S AN
IMPORT. OTHER ISSUES ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MISTER CASKEY. MISTER
GRAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER. NINE MM. OF
THE SERVICE SIXTY JUST. BODY
AND I APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE
ON THIS. INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
BILL ARE RELATED TO WORKER
SAFETY AND I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'VE HEARD
FROM EVERYONE. THAT HISTORY
ITSELF WHICH PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN EIGHT
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES. BATES FIVE
CENTER BRADFORD. I BRADFORD BY
SENATOR JONES. SAWYER JONES I
CENTER KAMLAGER I KAMLAGER
CENTER LAYER I EARLIER I WAS
CENTER RIGHT. NO CASTING. SIXTY
ONE THE- SIXTY ONE DAY YOU
MISTER. THANK YOU MEMBERS AND
IF WE COULD GO TO CERVANTES AND
OPEN THE ROLE ON AB EIGHT
NINETY. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
NINETY THE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR CHAIR VOTING
HIGH BY SURE VOTING NO CENTER
LAYERED ON THEIR LAYERED FIVE.
FINALISTS BY THE BILL IS OUT
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO OUR
REGULARLY SCHEDULED ORDER
BUSINESS GOING TO SCA ONE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG ON ELECTIONS-
SO THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
MUST CENTERS WAY PRESENTATION
SO WE'LL MOVE RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TO ANYONE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE IN SUPPORT
OF A CA ONE SEEING NOBODY IS
THERE ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY
SEEING NO ONE'S. MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF S. C. A. ONE. TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR S. C. A.
WANTED TO GET THAT RIGHT ISTER
CHAIR S. C. A. ONE S. C. A.
ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
FOLLOWED BY. ZERO AND NOBODY'S
GIVING UP ALL RIGHT WILL NOT
GOING OPPOSITION OF SCA ONE IS
THERE ANYONE WISHING TO OPPOSE
S. C. A. ONE. COMMA I REALLY
THINK HE I SHOULD MOVE UP TO
THE SECOND ROW TO SAVE US TIME.
ALL RIGHT SIR TELL US YOUR NAME
YOUR AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION. R. GRAHAM ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIANS WHO LEARNED
THAT SENATE STANDING COMMITTEES
ARE MULTI MEMBER BODIES THAT
ARE REQUIRED TO CONDUCT THEIR
MEETINGS OPENLY ALLOWING A
PLACE AT THE TABLE FOR THE
PUBLIC AND WE'RE OPPOSED. THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS PAUL GAVIN AND
WE'RE CALIFORNIANS WHO ACTUALLY
SPOKE TO WILLIAM T. BAGLEY
NINETY FOUR YEAR OLD FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THIS WEEKEND WE
LEARNED DIRECTLY FROM HIM THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT OF THE
BAGLEY KEENE ACT WE OPPOSE THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
MOVE ON TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SEEING NOBODY THEIR MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SCA ONE. IF YOU ARE
POSTED THE S. C. EIGHT ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN FALL BY
ZERO TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR S.
C. A. ONE. PARTICIPANTS ARE
QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION S. C. A. ONE C. NO
HAN SIR QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION IS
CA ONE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON S. C. H. TWO. BY
SENATOR ALLEN ON PUBLIC HOUSING
PROJECTS THIS IS ALSO SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE CENTERS WAY
PRESENTATIONS OR MOVE RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY. TO ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM SUPPORT OF A CA TO.
SEEING NO ONE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE SING KNOWN IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF S. C. A. TWO BY
SENATOR ALAN. SUPPORT FOR FCA
TO PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ONE FILED BY ZERO. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WE HAVE ONE CUED
UP. EVERYBODY ELSE GOING HIT
ONE ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR S.
C. A. TO. FIND EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
MARK STIVERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP IN STRONG
SUPPORT. FIVE SIXTY THREE YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER
ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. SURE
THERE ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION
OF A CA TO FIX ANYONE WISHING
TO OPPOSE I CA TO. NOW IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TELL US YOUR NAME
AND YOUR NEW ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION. MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MARKRAM ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIANS WHO IDENTIFIED
THAT EVERY SENATE STANDING
COMMITTEE IS SUBJECT TO OPEN
MEETING LAWS AND WE'RE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU SIR. ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION. YES HELLO MY NAME
IS PAULA KEVIN I'M CALIFORNIA
WHO KNOW THAT BY CALIFORNIA LAW
ALL COULD NINETEEN PROTOCOLS
EXPIRED ON AUGUST TWENTY NINTH
TWENTY TWENTY SO NONE OF THESE
COVERT NINETEEN PROTOCOLS ARE
REAL OR LEGAL AND WE OPPOSE THE
BILL ALL RIGHT I'M GONNA
CHALLENGE YOU TO FOR THE NEXT
TIME TO BE ABLE TO SAY YOUR
ORGANIZATION WITHOUT READING IT
CERTAIN NEGATIVE TAKE THIS TIME
TO MEMORIZE ORGANIZATIONS FOR
THE NEXT ONE ALL RIGHT NOPE
NOPE NOPE NOPE. JUST JUST. SIT
DOWN WITH. ALL RIGHT THAT'S ALL
RIGHT WE'VE HEARD FROM THIS
ROOM A ROOM THE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY AND NO ONE'S THERE
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TWO S. C.
A. TO. WELL THE SHOW PPOSITION
FOR S. C. A. TO PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE FILED BY ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION TO S. C. A. TO.
MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS QUEUING
UP. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION HAS BEEN
SAID THIS IS THE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE I'M- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DO YOU HAVE A FILE IN
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THESECRETARY OF STATE'S
COST PER PAGE PRICING MEASURE%
IN THE BALLOT PAMPHLET IS
APPROXIMATELY NINETY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. STATE THE
AVERAGE MEASURES APPROXIMATELY
FIVE TO NINETY AGENTS OR AN
ESTIMATED COST OF FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED NINETEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS. WE KNOW THAT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE IS ANNUALLY
APPROPRIATED FUNDING TO SUPPORT
THE COST OF PRINTING AND
MAILING THE STATE BORDER
INFORMATION GUIDE. AND
THEREFORE ANY COST TO PLACE
THIS MEASURE ON THE BALLOT
WOULD ONLY OCCUR IF THESE COSTS
COULD NOT BE SUPPORTED BY THE
CURRENT APPROPRIATIONS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU HAVEN'T HEARD
FROM SUPPORT OPPOSITION AND
FINANCE SEEING NO HANDS OF MY
COLLEAGUES GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION S. C. A. TO. WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO AB
SEVEN BY RODRIGUEZ ON EMERGENCY
AMBULANCE EMPLOYEES AGAIN THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. AND
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
WILL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN. THERE'S NO ONE RUSSIAN
IN THE MICROPHONE IN THIS ROOM
SO WE'LL GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THERE'S ONLY GHOSTS IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SO ABOUT OF
THE PHONE LINE. IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVEN. SUPPORT FOR A BI
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. SUPPORT FOR A BI SEVEN
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT WILL
MOVED OPPOSITION IS OR ANYONE
OPPOSED AB SEVEN IN THIS ROOM
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MARKRAM ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO LEARNED THAT
BY LAW. GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
COULD ONLY EXTEND THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY FOR UP TO TWO NINETY
DAY PERIODS AND WE'RE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
HE MET THE CHALLENGE LET'S SEE
IF YOU CAN. MY NAME IS PAUL
MCGOVERN AND I AM WITH
CALIFORNIANS ARE
ELECTROMAGNETIC WE SENSITIVE
AND WE OPPOSE ALL LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD MAKE US MOVE OUT OF
OUR HOMES AND WE OPPOSE THE
BILL THANK YOU GOOD JOB. ALL
RIGHT MOVING ON ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY EXCEPT HARVEY WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINE AND OUT OF
ANYBODY EVEN GOT THAT REFERENCE
MAYBE MR LEHRER KNOWS WHO
HARVEY IS. SEEING NO ONE IN
TWENTY FORTY MOST MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB. SEVEN TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR AB SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
OPPOSITION A. B. SEVEN PLEASE
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP MISTER
CHAIR. S. THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS ESTIMATES.
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE
DIVISION OF OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND HEALTH AND DENTAL AND THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL AND
THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY ESTIMATES ONE TIME
COST OF APPROXIMATELY ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE AND ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE HEARD FROM FINANCE
IS ANYONE HAVE A QUESTION
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP. WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SEVEN WAS OF THE
SUSPENSE I SEE MISTER
MURATSUCHI. HAS COME INTO THE
ROOM EVERYONE IS TRYING TO TAKE
MY GOOD GRACES FOR MR VINE
TASTES AND GETTING OUT OF TOWN.
QUICKLY SO SINCE I LET MS.
CERVANTES SAID MR GRAY MISTER
MURATSUCHI WILL LET YOU GO AS
WELL SO EVERYBODY WHO'S ON THE
PHONE LINE WE'RE GOING OUT OF
ORDER- I'M IN A GOOD MOOD SO
WE'RE GONNA AB TWO SEVEN NINE.
SO MISTER MURATSUCHI TELL US
ABOUT AB TWO SEVEN NINE BRIEFLY
ON THE INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITIES AND SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AGAIN FISCAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ABOUT SHERMAN
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AND THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORT YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL AB TWO SEVEN NINE IS A
BILL THAT WILL TEMPORARILY HALT
NURSING HOME EVICTIONS. AND
INVOLUNTARY TRANSFERS UNLESS
MEDICALLY NECESSARY DURING THE
CALL BUT NINETEEN STATE OF
EMERGENCY PERIOD. ACCORDING TO
THE A. R. P. WRITING IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL- MOVING READ. FROM
THEIR HOMES CAN BE UNSAFE AND
TRAUMATIC FOR THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES PARTICULARLY WHEN A
MOVE IS INVOLUNTARY AND SUDDEN.
THE A. R. P. HIGHLIGHT HOW.
NURSING HOMES DURING THIS
PANDEMIC HAVE BEEN TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF HIGHER
REIMBURSEMENT RATES WHETHER FOR
KOBE NINETEEN PATIENTS. WHETHER
FOR PRIVATE INSURANCE OR WHAT
WHAT THE FOR MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES. THIS BILL
SEEKS AGAIN TO A- TEMPORARILY.
DURING THE CALL BUT NINETEEN
STATE OF EMERGENCY PERIOD HOLD
NURSING HOME EVICTIONS
INVOLUNTARY TRANSFERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL IS MIKE DARK- BE HAPPY THE
NURSING CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
FOR NURSING HOME REFORM. YEAH
ALL MARKET I BELIEVE SO
MONTEREY- CAN YOU QUEUE UP OUR
WITNESS PLEASE- IF YOU ARE IF
YOU ARE ON THE LINE JUST GO
AHEAD UNDER YOURSELF. MAYBE
THEY CALL THEM. I BET THEY'D
CALLED IN AS A PARTICIPANT AS
WELL- WE DIDN'T KNOW THAT I'D
LIKE SIXTY THREE. DEMOCRATS ON
THE LINE SIXTY THREE BECAUSE
THEY QUEUED UP FOR THE
PARTICIPANT NOT AS A WITNESS
BUT LET'S TRY PLAN SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS I'M I'M NOT THE
WITNESS BUT THE I'M GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE
SUPPORT. SORRY MISTER CHAIR
HEIGHT. I WAS JUST TRYING TO
FIND THAT PERSON WE'D HE'S NOT
IN. THEY'RE DOING THE BEST YOU
CAN MY FRIEND. ALL RIGHT ANYONE
ELSE SUCH AS CO ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN OH TO ME.
TWO SEVEN NINE. THE EXPRESSED
SUPPORT FOR AB TWO SEVEN NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE FILED BY
ZERO ONE MOMENT WE ARE SOME
PARTICIPANTS KILLING UP.
EVERYBODY ELSE GOING HIT ONE
ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI
TWO SEVEN NINE WE ARE GETTING
QUITE A FEW. FIND NINE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD NINETY.
TECHNICALLY THE GREEN LINE-
YOUR OPEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GOOD AFTERNOON ARE ON- YES IT
IS GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARICO YAMADA
ALSO FORMER CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY AGING AND LONG TERM
CARE COMMITTEE FROM. TWENTY TEN
TO TWENTY FOURTEEN IN STRONG
SUPPORT A BABY TWO SEVEN NINE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NICE TO
HEAR YOUR VOICE AMERICA. AND TO
SEE YOU AS WELL. DESIGNS
DESIGNS SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE ADDAMS. OKAY SIXTY
NINE YEAR OLD BEYOND. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE AND
SHARE THIS IS CHRISTIANITY
MAINTENANCE ON BEHALF OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB BONTA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
PORTANTINO AND MEMBERS THIS IS
DOCTOR DAVID EASY MALDONADO.
SAVE OUR SENIORS I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVENTY NINE
THANK YOU. FIVE FIFTY EIGHT YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN PORTANTINO AND MEMBERS
THIS IS DOCTOR CAN NAKAYAMA OF
SOCCER ICF FAMILY COUNCIL IN I%
AM IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU.
FIVE SIXTY ONE YOU ARE UP
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TAIJI
MIYAGAWA- MEMBER OF PROGRESSIVE
ASIAN NETWORK FOR ACTION
CALLING IN TO EXPRESS STRONG
SUPPORT FOR A BI TEN SEVENTY
NINE THANK YOU. I AM EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE ON DR
KENNETH TIGHE ISHIDA- CHAIRMAN
OF THE CATO PACIFICA COMMUNITY
ADVISORY BOARD CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THE
FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWO SEVEN
NINE. NINE SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANKS I'M ACTUALLY THE
WITNESS PROVIDES DISCOUNT MY
WAY TO THIS LINE MY NAME IS
MIKE DARK I'M A STAFF ATTORNEY
AT CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM IN SAN
FRANCISCO. I'M ON PROFIT
POUNDED TO ADVOCATE FOR
CALIFORNIANS IN LONG TERM CARE.
AS THE MEMBERS LED AB TWO SEVEN
NINE PROVIDES AN ESSENTIAL
SHORT TERM HOLD. ELECTIONS
DURING THE CALL THE STATE
EMERGENCY. ELDERLY AND DISABLED
PEOPLE LIVING IN NURSING HOMES
AND INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITIES UNFORTUNATELY IT
ALSO AT NEGLIGIBLE COST TO THE
STATE OR TO HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS. UNLIKE OTHER FEDERAL
STATE AND COUNTY LEVEL. KOBE
DEPICTION MORATORIUM. AND
CALLED COORDINATE TWO SEVEN
NINE COMES AT NO COST YOU TO
THE POINT. THAT ACTOR LAMBEAU.
CONTINUE COLLECTING THE AND
FEDERAL REIMBURSED FOR THEIR
RESIDENTS. WELL NO CONCERNS
REGARDING **** TO THE STATE
WHERE EVER RATE IN THE ASSEMBLY
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
CONCLUDED THAT CAUCUS CO
CREATED WITH THE BILL WERE
NEGLIGIBLE. AT THE ELEVENTH
HOUR BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
DISCUSSION CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. F.
COMMITTEE OF THE ON THE
OVERSIGHT COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE BILL BETTER PHONE
SURPRISING AND UNFOUNDED AT THE
RATE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE ORDER
YOU ARE YOU. FOR EXAMPLE THE
LION'S SHARE OF THE PROJECTED
COST TO THE DEPARTMENT ABOUT
THREE POINT SIX MILLION FOR
OVERSIGHT COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
STAFFING CLOTHING
PERSONALITIES. ARE IN FACT
BORNE BY THE FEDERAL MEDICARE
PROGRAM AND THE JOINT FEDERAL
STATE MEDICAL PROGRAM. AND
ACCORDINGLY DO NOT ATTACK PDP
EIGHT AT ALL IN FACT THE
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATE WHICH IS A
LITTLE BIT LOOK SIMILAR ERRORS.
IT'S SO UNRELIABLE AND PROVIDE
NO GUIDANCE COMMITTEE AT ALL
SHOULD BE REJECTED. THANKS.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
IBOOK. ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE
SENATORS. AND WE DO HAVE ONE
OTHER KILLINGS HAPPEN AS THE
OPERATORS GIVEN THEIR LINE
NUMBER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO THE FINAL
REMINDER FOR AB. TWO SEVEN
NINE. AND WE WILL LINE NINETY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT NINETY
ONE YOU ARE OPEN. PLEASE ON THE
LINE. WE NEED YOU. TAKE NAME OF
SOME INTERNATIONAL MY NAME IS
FRANK MY I NEED FOR MY FAMILY
MEMBER BALK AT THE IDEA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY TWO
SEVENTY NINE. WHETHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT
WE'LL TAKE IN THE SUPPORT WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO OPPOSITION. WHAT
IS THE FOCUS. I'M SORRY. HEY WE
WANT TO THEMSELVES ARE YOU GUYS
HERE FOR SUPPORT ALL RIGHT.
TELL US WHO YOU ARE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ROUGH GOAL
KALIAN YANG OF LEGISLATIVE
STAFF REPORT ABOUT THE BECCLES
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT
DIRECTOR ALSO. A FORMER BOYLE
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER AND MEMBER
OF SAVE OUR SENIORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN PORTANTINO
AND MEMBERS MARKRAM ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIANS WHO WANT THE
STATE TO FREEZE ALL OF THE
TELECOMMUNICATION BILLS PENDING
THE COMPLETION BY DR THOMAS
ARAGON THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH OF HIS REVIEW OF THE
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH ON THE
HEALTH EFFECTS OF
ELECTROMAGNETIC FIELDS. AND WE
ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT MOVING ON
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR WE'VE TAKEN EVERYONE
I BELIEVE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT SO NOW WE'RE GONNA GO
BACK TO OPPOSITION. SO ANYONE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL IN THIS
ROOM IF YOU'RE OPPOSITION. COME
ON UP. MY NAME'S PALMER GAVIN
WE ARE FOR CONSISTENT
CALIFORNIANS WHO DO HAVE
OPPOSITION HERE AND THIS IS AND
RECOGNIZES THAT THE SENATE-
DAILY JOURNAL SHOULD BE TREATED
LIKE THE SENATE DAILY FILE AND
SHOULD KEEP PACE YET IT LAGS
BEHIND BY FOUR TO SIX WEEKS
THIS IS A BIG PROBLEM FOR THE
PUBLIC TO. UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
GOING A LITTLE BIT TOO FAR IN
YOUR ORGANIZATION ALL RIGHT
YOUR OPPOSED LET'S SEE IF WE
CAN BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
CONCISE ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO
ONE THERE ON THE PHONE LINE
ANYONE ELSE SUPPOSED TO. THIS
BILL. PROVIDER OF MOLDOVA
NINETY TWO SEVEN NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE FILED BY ZERO
CHAU OPPOSITION FOR AB TWO
SEVEN NINE. NOBODY IS KILLING A
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE A
FILE IN AB TWO SEVEN NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YES- WE
ARE CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO THE
MEASURE IS AS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED. I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
THAT PUBLIC HEALTH DOES NOT
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO COMPEL
FACILITY. TO CONTINUE OPERATING
OR PROVIDING SERVICES IT NO
LONGER IS ABLE TO FINANCIALLY
SUPPORT- SO THE CONCERN IS THAT
THERE CAN BE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE. SAFETY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
DOES ESTIMATE. OF POTENTIAL
COST OF FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS UP FROM A
SPECIAL. STATE HEALTH
FACILITIES CITATION PENALTIES
ACCOUNT FOR SIX MONTHS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
AND THIS IS BASED ON THE
ASSUMPTION OF THREE VOLUNTARY
CLOSURES. OF INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITIES. AND SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES BETWEEN NOW AND JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'VE HEARD FOR
FINANCE ANY QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. MISS BATES. YEAH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI JUST
A QUICK QUESTION ABOUT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S INVOLVEMENT
YOU KNOW THAT THEY ARE ON THERE
HAD BEEN AN OUTREACH TO THAT
OFFICE BUT TO DATE I. HAVE NOT
HEARD THAT THERE'S ANY RESPONSE
IN TERMS OF THEIR ROLE IN
ENFORCEMENT. OF ISSUES WITH
NORTH WITH. ISSUES LIKE THIS
YES THANK YOU SENATOR- WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL THE
BILL THAT DEALS WITH. THE
IMPOSITION OF CONDITIONS OF
SALE OF ACT OF HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES FROM NONPROFIT TO
FOR PROFIT- OWNERS. THE
PARTICULAR- NURSING HOME IN ICF
INVOLVED THAT THAT- INSPIRED
THIS BILL- INVOLVED THAT KIND
OF A SITUATION WHERE. THERE WAS
A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
SOLD OUT FOR NURSING HOMES AND
MEDICARE FACILITIES TO A. FOR
PROFIT THAT FOR PROFIT.
ANNOUNCED TO ALLOW YEAR THAT IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE OF THE
PANDEMIC THE LAST SEPTEMBER
THAT THEY WANTED TO CONVERT-
ONE OF THE FACILITIES INTO A-
INTO LUXURY APARTMENTS AND- AND
SO THAT IS THE- THE INVOLVEMENT
OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IN THIS.
THE COMMISSION THANK YOU MISTER
JONES HAS A QUESTION AS WELL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER
MURATSUCHI A QUESTION AND
CONCERN- YOUR YOUR WITH LEAD
WITNESS AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ACTUALLY PICKED UP ON
ON MY CONCERN AND THAT'S THE-
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. PUT THE- FISCAL
AFFECTED NEGLIGIBLE- BUT ALSO
SAID ACTUAL COSTS ARE UNKNOWN.
BUT POTENTIALLY COULD BE
SIGNIFICANT DEPENDING ON A
NUMBER OF FACILITIES THAT FILE
FOR BANKRUPTCY BETWEEN.
EFFECTIVE DATE OF THE BILL IN
THE AND THE SUNSET AND THEN. AS
WAS POINTED OUT A CITY PH CAME
IN WITH AN ESTIMATE OF FOUR
POINT- TWO MILLION DOLLARS-
JUST WANTED TO KNOW IF YOU WANT
TO SPEAK TO THAT DISPARITY IN
THE- IN THOSEOPINIONS AND THE
CONCERN IS. THAT THE ONLY
EXEMPTION IS BANKRUPTCY DOES
THIS NOT HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
FORCE. SOME OF THESE-
FACILITIES IN THE BANKRUPTCY
AND TO SEEK THAT PROTECTION
THANK YOU SIR FOR YOUR QUESTION
AS A- THE WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL TESTIFIED TO. THESE
NURSING HOMES AN INTERMEDIATE
CARE FACILITIES THEY ARE
BASICALLY GUARANTEED- AND COME
WHETHER IT'S MEDICARE OR
MEDICAID ALL IN TERMS OF THEIR
THEIR CURRENT PATIENTS WHAT
THIS BILL IS ASKING FOR IS A
TEMPORARY. A TEMPORARY RELIEF
THE TEMPORARY PEACE OF MIND FOR
OUR MOST VULNERABLE- SENIORS-
WE SAW THAT SENIORS LIVING IN
NURSING HOMES DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND ALL. HAVE BEEN
AMONG THE MOST VULNERABLE
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND IN FACT
ACCOUNTED FOR ALMOST HALF OF
ALL THE DOUBTS IN THE EARLY
MONTHS OF THE OF THE PANDEMIC.
THIS AGAIN I MEAN IT'S ONE IT
IS WE LIMITED IT TO THE STATE
OF EMERGENCY PERIOD- PUT BUT-
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS RAISED IN
THE SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE
THEY EVEN THEY THEY LIMITED
THE- THE THEY THAT THEY SUNSET
AT THE BILL UP FOR JULY FIRST
OF NEXT YEAR AND SO. YOU KNOW
WE BELIEVE THAT THE- NO LONGER
RESPECT AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH- TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS- THAT THEY ARE. YOU
KNOW PROJECTING A WORST CASE
SCENARIO WHERE IF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WOULD HAVE TO INTERVENE WITH-
WITH THE NURSING HOME OF ICY
ALPS THAT- THAT MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE TO OPERATE WE.
HAVEN'T SEEN YOU KNOW- MAY OF
THIS- BANKRUPTCY OR VOLUNTARILY
CLOSING DURING THE PANDEMIC- WE
ARE ASKING FOR. THE BALANCING
OF THE EQUITIES SO TO SPEAK IN
IN IN TERMS OF. YOU KNOW
SHOWING COMPASSION FOR NURSING
HOME RESIDENTS YOU JUST DURING
THIS LIMITED PERIOD OF TIME SO
THAT WE DON'T EXPOSE THEM TO.
TO INFECTION OR TRANSFER TRAUMA
THANK. THANK YOU I'VE I'VE-
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE CONCEPT
OF THE BILL SO- WORKING ON
THOSE ISSUES ALL A LAUGH TODAY
AND THEN FIGURE OUT WHAT.
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION WE
RECEIVE IN THE COMING WEEKS
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT- QUESTION
THIS IS A DO PASS WE HAVE A
MOTION- MR MARSHALL CHU WOULD
YOU LIKE TO BRIEFLY CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL ALL
RIGHT. MISTER CONSULTANT CALL
THE ROLL. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
SEVENTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE FLOOR SIR
PORTANTINO HIPORTANTINO I
SENATOR BATES. BATES HI CENTER
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE SENATOR
JONES. CENTER KAMLAGER THANK
KAMLAGER BYE CENTER LAYERED HI
THERE HI CENTER ACCOUNTS HI.
FIVE OF. SIX ZERO FOUR SIX ZERO
SIX ZERO. MR DALY I SEE YOU
SHOWED UP ALSO HOPING TO PREY
UPON MY GOOD SPIRITS AND THE
SENSE OF VACATION. SINCE I
ALLOWED HER COLLEAGUES TO GO
OUT OF ORDER I'M GOING TO DO
THIS ONCE BUT- IN THE FUTURE WE
WILL STICK TO THE ORDER IT'S
ONLY BECAUSE THIS IS GET AWAY
DAY THAT WE'RE DOING THIS. SO
AND- HOPEFULLY BREVITY IS PART
OF YOUR PRESENTATION. YES AB
FOURTEEN NINETY NINE.
TRANSPARENCY FOR ITS FOR TATIAN
DESIGN BUILD HIGHWAYS. AND
EVERYONE WHO'S LISTENING WE'RE
TAKING THIS OUT OF ORDER IT'S A
BE FOURTEEN NINETY NINE. GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS BILL IS A SIMPLE
SUNSET EXTENSION AUTHORIZING
THE USE OF THE DESIGN BUILD
METHOD OF PROCUREMENT FOR STATE
HIGHWAY CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS.
IT EXTENDS THE SUNSET FOR TEN
YEARS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT- WE
WILL GO DO YOU HAVE WITNESSES.
IN SUPPORT. I DON'T BELIEVE SO
OR ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT NOW ANYBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY NO MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINES IN SUPPORT
OF AB. FOURTEEN NINETY NINE. TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI
FOURTEEN NINETY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WHEN FOLLOWED BY
ZERO TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A
BI ONE FOUR NINE NINE WILL
BEGIN WITH ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. STRICTURE
MEMBER STEVE BAKER WITH THEIR
NEEDS ASSISTANCE FOR THE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT IN
SUPPORT. NINE EIGHTY FIVE YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MOIRA TOP ON
BEHALF OF ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT. THE FINAL REMINDER TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB ONE FOUR
NINE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. EIGHTY EIGHT YOU
ARE UP. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN KEITH DONE THE WHOLE
COUNTIES COALITION IN SUPPORT.
AND WE HAVE EXHAUSTED THE Q.
MISTER CHAIR. OF WHERE EXACTLY.
TEN HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT WILL
NOT OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED AB.
FOURTEEN NINETY NINE. YES
CHAIRMAN PORTANTINO ONE MEMBERS
MARK GRAHAM ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD CREATE A SEARCHABLE
DATABASE FOR ALL THE POSITION
MATTERS THAT ARE SUBMITTED TO
THE LEGISLATURE'S WEB PORTAL.
AND WE'RE OPPOSED. I ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION. FORTY NINETY NINE.
BOB PAULEY GAVIN FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
DOCUMENTED IN PLACE IN THE
PUBLIC RECORD OUT PROCEDURAL
ERRORS IN BILLS YOU WILL FACE
AN AUGUST APPROPRIATIONS AND WE
OPPOSE THE BILL. ALL RIGHT
MOVING ON THE ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SAYING NO ONE THERE. ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB.
FOURTEEN NINETY NINE. CHAU
OPPOSITION FOR AB FOURTEEN
NINETY NINE. PLEASE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY M. PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NOBODY IS
KILLING UP MISTER CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE HAVE A FILE
ON A. B. FOURTEEN NINETY NINE.
NO NO FILE THIS YEAR ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
SINGLE QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES MISTER DALY WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ON THIS DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ALL RIGHT THAT'S A GREAT
CLOTHES WE HAVE A MOTION MR
LAYERED MOVED SO MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
NINETY NINE MOTIONS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO
HI PORTANTINO I SENATOR BATES
BATES AYE CENTER BRADFORD
BRADFORD DODD SENATOR JONES
JONES I CENTER KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER TYSON- LAYERED HI
THERE I SENATOR CASSIDY HI DOES
HE ARE SEVEN ZERO. BILLS OUT
SEVEN ZERO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO YOUR INSURANCE OMNIBUS BILL.
AB FIFTEEN ELEVEN. PLEASE TELL
US BRIEFLY ABOUT AB FIFTEEN
ELEVEN THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS THE ANNUAL
INSURANCE COMMITTEE OMNIBUS
BILL WHICH CONTAINS NON
CONTROVERSIAL PROPOSALS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE AWESOME- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT MISTER MCCAMLY COME ON
UP. YES MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CHRIS MAKAYLA ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CLAIMS
PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT OF MR
DALY BILL THANK YOU. S. ALL
RIGHT I BELIEVE WE HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE ON THE
COASTLINE THAT WANTS TO SPEAK.
CANADA'S DOLLAR DEPUTY
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR ON BEHALF
OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA AND DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE THE CARD. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SIR YOU CAN COME BACK
UP NOW FOR. HI PAUL MCGOVERN
FOR- CONFLUENCE WHO RECOGNIZE
THAT- LLOYDS OF LONDON ALL
REINSURERS DO NOT INSURE INJURY
ILLNESS OR DEATH OR MICROWAVE
RADIATION AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL. ALL RIGHT. MOVING ON TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE MODERATOR AND
WALLS ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN ELEVEN.
SO SUPPORT FOR A BI FIFTEEN
ELEVEN PLEASE PRESS STAR
FOLLOWED BY ONE AT THIS TIME.
ONE FOR SKEWS ME ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN PAUL
BY ZERO SHOW SUPPORT. AND
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT REMOVED OPPOSITION OF
AB FIFTEEN ELEVEN. SIR COME ON
UP. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
PORTANTINO AND MEMBERS MARKRAM
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
RECOMMEND THAT THIS COMMITTEE
SHOULD RESTORE PUBLIC SPEAKING
TIMES TO THEIR TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN LEVELS CONSISTENT
WITH THE OPEN MEETINGS LAWS
THAT APPLY TO SENATE STANDING
COMMITTEES AND WE'RE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU OF IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SINGNOBODY THERE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO AB.
FIFTEEN ELEVEN. TO OPPOSITION
FOR AB FIFTEEN ELEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME I'M FILED BY ZERO.
THE JOURNAL BUT HE IS GOING UP.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION APARTMENT FINANCED
YOU HAVE A FILE. FILE THIS YEAR
NO FILE ALL RIGHT WE'VE HEARD
FROM EVERYONE. MR DALY WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ALL RIGHT
ANY NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. WE HAVE A MOTION
FOR MISTER CHOW SKEET MISTER
MODERATE MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
ELEVEN MOTIONS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO.
AYE PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR
BATES. BATES SENATOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE CENTER JONES JONES
I CENTER KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER ICE
EARLIER. I CENTER CASKEY HI
KANSKE FIVE SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO WE'VE
TAKEN CARE OF ALL THE DO PASSED
MOTIONS WERE GONNA GO BACK TO
ALL OF OUR SUSPENSE CANDIDATES
WERE GOING BACK TO- MR
RODRIGUEZ- A. B. SEVEN I
BELIEVE RIGHT. WE DID THAT ONE
I DIDN'T FOR THE LAST FRIDAY
OKAY AB FIVE THREE SIX RESTORE
ACCOUNTS HE'S GONNA TAKE OVER
BRIEFLY WITH AB. FIVE THREE
SIX. OKAY THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CALENDAR AND- SOMEONE ORDERED
REDUCES WAY PRESENTATION SO
LET'S MOVE RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN OUR ROOMS FORTY TWO OR
THREE. THEY WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A AB FIVE
THREE SIX. SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANYBODY IN ROOM FOUR. TWENTY
FORTY TESTS FIND SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE. SEEING NONE- PUTS
ME THROUGH A MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WE NEED TESTIFYING
SUPPORT VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE THREE SIX.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TO
ACTUAL SUPPORT FOR A BI FIVE
THREE SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE FILED BY
ZERO FOR SUPPORT AB FIVE THREE
SIX. NOBODY IS COMING UP AT
THIS TIME OKAY LET'S FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCEDURE AND NOT WITH
OPPOSITION I DO HAVE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF AB- FIVE THREE
SIX MISTER GRAMMY RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU- SENATOR AND MEMBERS
MARK GRAHAM. ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO. POINT OUT
THAT THE PERMITTING SYSTEM FOR
THE ISSUANCE OF CELL ANTENNA
PERMITS IS CURRENTLY WORKING
AND DOES NOT NEED TO BE FIXED
AND WE'RE OPPOSED. THANK YOU
MISMA KEVIN YOU RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU I'M PAUL MCGAVIN-
CALIFORNIA YOUR ACTUAL SOFTWARE
ENGINEERS AND USED A HEX EDITOR
TO OPEN UP THE SENATE DAILY
JOURNAL AND WE HAVE UNCOVERED
PROBLEMS THAT WE WILL BE
PUTTING ON THE RECORD THANK YOU
VERY COULD SEE NO OTHER
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE WILL TURN TURN OF
ROOM FOR- TWENTY FORTY I SEE NO
WITNESSES WE'RE WILLING TO
TESTIFY IN A POSITION OF. FIVE
TO SIX MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES.
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION AB FIVE THREE SIX.
EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR AB FIVE
THREE SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. IN I'M FILED
BY ZERO FOR OPPOSITION AB FIVE
THREE SIX. NOBODY IS QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR
COULDN'T CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING
TURNED- DEPARTMENT FINANCE MISS.
A NOTE THERE ARE TO HAVE A FILE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE-IT RESULTS IN SIGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT
INCLUDED. IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CURRENT FISCAL
PLAN OR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET I CARILLO YES ESTIMATES
COST APPROXIMATELY FIVE POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND ON GOING TO IMPLEMENT THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE STILL. VERY
GOOD MEMBERS WHO HAVE ANY QUICK
QUESTIONS SEEING NONE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB FIVE THREE SIX IS MOVED TO
DISPENSE FILED. NOW MR
RODRIGUEZ HAS AB- SIX ONE FIVE
ON HIGHER. EDUCATION AND
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS HE IS WAIT
IT IS A SUSPENSE COUNTER IN HIS
WAY PRESENTATION- SO LET'S WITH
HERE FROM THOSE WITNESSES. IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE ROOMS
WERE IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX ONE
SEVEN SIX ONE FIVE SKEWS ME. I
SEE NO WITNESSES HERE IN THE
ROOM SCHOOLROOM TWENTY FORTY.
AND SALAS FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SIX. SB SIX ONE FIVE
I SEE NONE SO LET'S MOVE TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF. VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
SUPPORT OF AB SIX ONE FIVE. WE
LIKE TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI SIX ONE
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE FILED
BY ZERO. M. STRUCTURE WE HAVE
NO PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP VERY
GOOD WAS GOOD OPPOSITION-
WITNESSES. HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE WHO WOULD WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB SIX
ONE FIVE MISTER GRAHAM YOUR
WORK RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU
SENATOR LIKE HEALTHY MEMBERS
MARKRAM ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO WISH TO REMIND
YOU THAT AS RECENTLY CONFIRMED
BY THE U. S. COURT OF APPEALS
FOR THE NINTH CIRCUIT. CITY'S
RETAIN THE JURISDICTION TO
IMPOSE AESTHETIC REGULATIONS ON
THE PLACEMENT OF CELL ANTENNAS
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THAT SHOULD
BE LOOKED LEFT INTACT. WERE
OPPOSED. VERY GOOD. THIS
PROGRAM IN YOUR YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SIX ONE FIVE. YES I'M CALLING
THE GOVERNOR WITH CALIFORNIANS
WHO RECOGNIZE THE BROADBAND
IMPROVEMENTS ARE NECESSARY BUT
THEY MUSTBE WITH BILLS THAT
ARE ACTUALLY TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL
ANY SUCH AMENDMENTS THAT CHANGE
THAT MUST BE STRUCK AND WE
OPPOSE THE BILL. VERY GOOD
SCENE OR THE WITNESSES IN ROOM
FOR FORTY TWO OR THREE WILL
MOVE TO WHAT WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. I SEE NINE AN OPT
IN WISHING TO TESTIFY IN A
POSITION. TO SIX ONE FIVE SO
LET'S MOVE ON. TO THE-
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATE CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP. WITNESSES MOTION WHICH I
TESTIFIED. IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SIX ONE FIVE. BACK TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR AB SIX ONE FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
AB. SIX FIFTEEN. AND WE HAVE NO
PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME IS VERY WELL CLOSE PUBLIC
HEARING AND MOVED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MISS
UNDER THERE AND YOU HAVE A
FILE. ON SIX NINE. BILL FILE
OKAY- VERY GOOD WITHOUT A TRIP
OBJECTION AB SIX MONTHS FIVE IS
MOVED TO SUSPENSE FILE DUMP. M.
S. AMERICA SAYS AB AB. TEN
SEVENTY ONE ON THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCIES IT IS A CANDIDATE
FOR SUSPENSE IN HIS WAY
PRESENTATION SO LET'S MOVE TO
THE PUBLIC HEARING ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES HEARING ROOM
FORTY TWO THREE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB. TEN
SEVENTY ONE. SEEING NONE WILL
MOVE TO- ROOM TWENTY FORTY TO
SEE IF ANYBODY TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT OF AB TEN SEVENTY ONE I
SEE NONE. LET'S MOVE TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC GOING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR CAN YOU QUEUE UP. ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT OF AB TEN SEVENTY ONE.
SUPPORT FOR A BI TEN SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AB TEN SEVENTY ONE.
PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUING UP
MISTER CHAIR VERY GOOD LET'S
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCEDURE FOR
THE OPPOSITION A TEN SEVENTY
ONE OF THE WITNESSES HERE. IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE WHICH THE
TEST BY MR GRAHAM YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU SENATOR Y.
CATHKIN MEMBERS MARKRAM ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
PREFERS CITY OWNED COMMUNITY
BROADBAND PROJECT TO PROVIDE
HIGH SPEED INTERNET ACCESS AND
CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE WITH
NO ELECTROMAGNETIC RADIATION.
AND WE ARE OPPOSED. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU. MISPRINT EVAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
SENATOR MCCASKEY ON PALMA GAVIN
AND I'M WITH CALIFORNIANS WHO
AGREED WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
TREASURY JUNE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
STAKE IN THE GROUND SAYING
BROADBAND MUST BE ADDRESSED
WITH A HUNDRED MEGABITS PER
SECOND SYMMETRIC SERVICE BOTH
UP AND DOWN. AND WIRELESS
BROADBAND CANNOT ACHIEVE THAT
WE OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY GOOD ALL RIGHT SEE NO
OTHER WITNESSES AND ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE WAS TRYING TO ROOM
AT TWENTY FORTY ROUTE THERE ARE
OVERFLOW TO SEE IF THERE
WITNESSES TESTIFYING I SEE NONE
MODERATOR LET'S GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE. SERVICE OF
WITNESSES WISHING TO TESTIFY.
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TEN SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE. LET THE SELF
DISTURBANCES. THANK YOU IF YOU
ARE OPPOSED TO A BE A TEN
SEVENTY ONE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY IN PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP COULDN'T CLOSE
PUBLIC HEARING TURNED TO THE
PARTNER FINANCE MISS UNDER
THERE AND YOU HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR ALTHOUGH THE BUILD
REQUIRES CALLOW YES TO THE
GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE HE'S-
AND FUNDING TO OFFSET STATE
LOCAL AND TRIBAL GOVERNMENT
COSTS A CALORIE AS DOES
ESTIMATED WILL REQUIRE A
MINIMUM OF THREE POSITIONS AND
SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY.
TO PLAN COORDINATE AND CONDUCT
REQUIRED TABLE TOP EXERCISES.
YOU COULD BRING IT BACK TO
MEMBERS SAYING NO HANDS UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TEN
SEVENTY ONE IS MOVED TO
SUSPENSE FILE. NEXT MISTER
RODRIGUEZ SAYS AB. ELEVEN OH
FIVE AND HOSPITAL WORKERS INCO
PROTESTING IT IS SPENCE
CANDIDATE HE'S WAVE-
PRESENTATION- SO LET'S MOVE TO
THE PUBLIC HEARING IS ANYBODY
HERE. IN ROOM FORTY TWO THREE
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB ELEVEN OH FIVE SEEING NONE
WAS MOVED TO WITNESSES
SENATE-ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
INSUPPORTABLE AB ELEVEN OH FIVE
SEEING NONE- LET'S GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF VIA
TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP THE FIRST WITNESS.
WHICH CONTESTS ARE IN SUPPORT
OF ELEVEN OH FIVE. ELEVEN OH
FIVE. SUPPORT FOR A BI ELEVEN
OH FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE FILED BY
ZERO FOR SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
OH FIVE. WE HAVE NO
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME VERY GOOD WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION NOW IS THERE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO THREE WHICH TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION OF A. B. A LEVEL
FIVE MISTER GRAHAM YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU SENATOR Y.
CATHKIN MEMBERS MARKRAM ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
RECOGNIZE THAT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE THE CITY OF
CHATTANOOGA TENNESSEE HAS HAD A
CITY OWNED COMMUNITY BROADBAND
PROJECT. THAT HAS CREATED MANY
JOBS AND SAVED MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. AND WE'RE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU MR DEVIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED- THANK YOU CENTER
CASKEY MONIES PALMA GABBER OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO AGREE WITH
SENATE REQUIRES IMPASSIONED
SPEECH YESTERDAY ON AB ONE FIVE
SIX THE BROADBAND BUDGET BILL.
AND HOW THESE- INCUMBENT
COMPANIES HAVEN'T SOLVED THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE AND THAT'S WHY
CITIES CAN DO IT WHEN THEY
RECOVER THE MONEY THAT WAS
EARMARKED FOR IT SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY THREE. WE OPPOSE THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU SEEN
THE WEATHER WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE WILL
TURN TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS HE
PEOPLE WISH TO TESTIFY SCENE.
NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THERE
SO LET'S MOVE TO THE WITNESSES
WHEN THE TEST FIVE YEARS OUR
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERTOR CAN YOU PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN OH FIVE.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT FOR A BI
ELEVEN OH FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NO
PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUING UP
VERY GOOD WILL CLOSE PUBLIC
HEARING MOVED TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE FINANCE MISS. UNDER
THERE AND YOU HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL. IF I MISTER CHAIR
ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD I SEE NO
HAN HELLO AMANDA VICE CHAIR BAY
TO RECOGNIZE I JUST MAKE A
COMMENT ON THIS ONE I THINK
THAT THE CONCERT SO SIGNIFICANT
STATE COSTS. IN WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT PUTTING A BURDEN
LIKE HAVE FUN HOUSE MIDDLES. OF
FOR THE LENGTH OF TIME WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT I THINK THIS
REALLY NEEDS I AM VERY CLOSER
LOOK AT THE- COSTS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE IMPOSED ON OUR
HOSPITAL SYSTEM- THIS ONE SEEMS
TO BE QUITE AN OVER REACH WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT I THINK THE
DATE THAT. GOES OUT TO TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT FROM TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE I THINK IT IS. FIVE FOUR
NOT OUT OF THE EMERGENCY BY
THAT TIME I. AM NOT SURE WILL
HAVE A HOSPITAL STANDING SO.
PLEASE MAKE A NOTE IF YOU WOULD
ON THE RECORD THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE SOMETHING VERY SPECIFIC ON
THE PART OF. THAT THIS IS GOING
TO THE POLLS ON A HOSPITAL
SYSTEM. THANK YOU. THE RECORD
WILL NOTE YOUR- YOUR CONCERNS
AND WITHOUT FURTHER OBJECTION
AB ELEVEN OH FIVE IS MOVES THIS
IS SUSPENSE CALENDAR- YEAH I'LL
MOVE TO A. B. FIFTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. ON EERGENCY SERVICES.
ALSO BY A SEVEN MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ HE'S IT IS DISPENSED
CALENDAR EACH WEEK PRESENTATION
SO WE'LL MOVE DIRECTLY TO.
SUPPORT OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF. AB FIFTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT I SEE NONE WILL MOVE TO
SEE IF THERE'S WITNESSES AN IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY I SEE NINTH.
IN SUPPORT SO- PLEASE LET'S
MOVE TO THE PUBLIC. THOSE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLICLY NAY
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE
UP MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT OF AB. FIFTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. SUPPORT FOR A BI. SIXTY
EIGHT. PRESS ONE FOR BY Z. ONE
FOLLOWED BY FOR B. FIFTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT. AND NOBODY IS
KILLING UP MR CHERRY GOODNESS
BECAUSE THE OPPOSITION FURTHER
ANYWHERE WITNESSES SAID. ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF AB. FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
MISTER GRAMMER RECOGNIZE. THANK
YOU SENATOR AKAKA MEMBERS
MARKRAM ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO BELIEVE THAT
THE STATE SHOULD SPEND SOME OF
THE AMERICAN RECOVERY PLAN ACT
MONEY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON CITY OWNED
COMMUNITY BROADBAND PROJECTS
LIKE THE ONE IN CHATTANOOGA.
TENNESSEE AND WE'RE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU. FIVE MISMA KEVIN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
CENTER CASSIE PALMA GAVIN I
WITH CALIFORNIANS WHO KNOW THAT
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICE HAS
ONLY NEEDS SIGNAL STRENGTH OF
MINUS EIGHTY FIVE DBM YET IN
SACRAMENTO WE HAVE MEASURED
MINUS TEN DBM AND A SECOND
STORY BEDROOM THIS IS US THANK
WAY TOO MUCH WE OPPOSE THE
BILL. BURKE GOOD LET'S SEE FOR
WITNESSES IN OUR OVERFLOW ROOM-
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY. SEEING NINE LET'S GO
BACK TO THE TELECONFERENCE EVER
SINCE HE OF YOUR WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT MODERATOR. PLEASE Q. ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO TESTIFY
AGAINST AB FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT.
OUR SERVICE SORRY MY MUTE
BUTTON WAS ACTING FUNNY THERE I
APOLOGIZE CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW
YES WE CAN. THANK YOU SORRY-ABOUT THAT TO SHOW OPPOSITION
FOR AB ONE FIVE SIX EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. NOBODY IS KILLING UP. A
VERY GOOD LET'S CLOSE PUBLIC
HEARING TURNED TO MISS ON THE
DERA WITH THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE HAVE A FILE ON. THE
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT COMMITTEES
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE OR WILL
RESULT IN GENERAL FUND COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THAT TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT AND
ONGOING HELLO YES ESTIMATES A
COST OF THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ON GOING.
TO IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL. OKAY SEEING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NOTING THE
PARTNER FINANCES OBJECTION THAT
OBJECTION FROM MEMBERS HERE AB
FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT IS MOST
DISPENSED FILE OUR NEXT ITEM ON
THE AGENDA IS AB FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS IS IT IS
ALSO A SUSPENSE CANDID AND HE'S
WAY PRESENTATION LET'S GO
IMMEDIATELY TO SUPPORT OTHER
ANYBODY HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
THREE WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY SIX SEEING
NONE WOULD TURN TO ROOM. TWENTY
FORTY I SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THERE SO LET'S MOVE ON
TO ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHICH THE TEST FIND SUPPORT VIA
TELECONFERENCE TO AB FIFTY SIX
MODERATOR PLEASE Q. OUR FIRST.
MEMBER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR AB FIVE
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO ONE FILED BY ZERO FOR
AB FIVE SIX. AND WE HAVE NO
PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME MISTER GOOD LET'S FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS IN A POSITION
OR THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO- THROUGH
WHICH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF. AB FIFTY SIX MISTER GRAHAM
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
SENATOR AKAKA MEMBERS MARKRAM
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
WANT TO SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE.
OUR INVOLUNTARY EXPOSURE TO
CELL ANTENNA. ELECTROMAGNETIC
RADIATION BECAUSE IT IS
DANGEROUS TO HUMAN HEALTH AND
WE'RE OPPOSED. GOOD THANK YOU-
MR GAVIN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU CENTER CASKEY PALMA
KEVIN- WITH CALIFORNIANS WHO
WANT TO CLARIFY THE MINUS TEN
DBM IS TWENTY FIVE MILLION
TIMES HIGHER THAN NEEDED FOR
FIVE BARS OF THE CELL PHONE AND
RESULTS IN CHILD ENDANGERMENT
AS WAS REPORTED TO DR TOMAS
ARAGON ON OCTOBER TWENTY SECOND
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN IN SAN
FRANCISCO WE OPPOSE THE BILL.
BURGER KING NO OTHER WITNESSES
HERE IN FORTY CHU THREE WAS
TRYING TO ROOMS TWENTY FORTY
THERE ARE NO WITNESSES THERE
WISHING TO TESTIFY MODERATOR
PLEASE Q. ANY WITNESSES VIA
TELECONFERENCE A SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH THE TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTY SIX.
THAT'S FINE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
FIFTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND NO
PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME VERY GOOD WILL CLOSE
PUBLIC HEARING TURN TO THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE MISS ON THE
GYORGY HAVE A FILE ON THIS
BILL. IF I MISTER CHAIR OKAY
WITH SEEING THEIR HANDS UP
WITH. MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE
DAYS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FIFTY
SIX IS MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
CALENDAR NEXT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS HAS AB TEN THIRTY FIVE
WHICH IS ALSO SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE HE IS WAVE
PRESENTATION SO LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
THIRTY FIVE SEEING NONE WILL
TURN TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY AND
SEE IF THIS MEMBERS THAT PUBLIC
SEEING NONE THERE'S A TO
SUPPORT LET'S TURN OUR
TELECONFERENCE RIVERS AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
THIRTY FIVE MISTER. MODERATOR.
PLEASE Q. ANY WITNESSES.
EXPRESS SUCH A FOR A BI TEN
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. FOUR AB.
TEN THIRTY FIVE. BUT NO
PARTICIPANTS KILLING OF MR
REGARDLESS FALL THE SAME-
PROCEDURE FOR THE OPPOSITION
OTHER WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE WHICH
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TEN THIRTY FIVE MISTER GRAHAM
YOUR RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU
SENATOR Y. CATHKIN MEMBERS
MARKRAM ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO READ THE STUDY
BY THE UNITED STATES NATIONAL
INSTITUTES OF HEALTH NATIONAL
TOXICOLOGY PROGRAM. NOVEMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THAT
FOUND CLEAR EVIDENCE OF CANCER
FROM CELL PHONE RADIATION AND
WE ARE OPPOSED. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU MISTER MCGAVIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. YES MY NAME'S PAUL
MCGAVIN WE'RE CALIFORNIANS WHO
RECOGNIZE THE DOCTOR TOMAS
SARGON THE HEAD OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
IS A MEDICAL DOCTOR AND HE IS A
MANDATED REPORTER FOR
CONDITIONS OF CHILD
ENDANGERMENT HE IS KNOWN ABOUT
THIS SINCE OCTOBER TWENTY
SECOND TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WE
WOULD LIKE HIM TO REPORT THAT
TO OUR SENATORS AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS. THANK YOU OPPOSE THE
BILL COULD SEE NO OTHER
WITNESSES HERE ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE I'LL TURN TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SENATORS WITNESSES
TESTIFY SEEING NONE. MODERATOR
LET'S Q. WITNESSES WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
THIRTY FIVE AND CALL THEM
FORWARD. THANK YOU TO- EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO A. B. TEN THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. BANNISTER
SURE NOBODY IS KILLING UP VERY
GOOD LET'S CLOSE PUBLIC CARE
INTERVENTION PARTNER FINANCE
MISSED ON THE DERA DO YOU HAVE
A FILE. YES THIS BILL IS NOT
ESTIMATED TO RESULT IN COSTA
CALTRANS WE WOULD NOTE THAT
REQUIRING LOCAL AGENCIES TO
ADOPT SPECIFIED RECYCLING
STANDARDS THE BILL MAY CREATE A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE
WHICH COULD RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT STATE COSTS. GOOD
SEEING NO HANDS UP I'M MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TEN THIRTY FIVE IST MOVED TO
SUSPEND CALENDAR NOW WE'RE
TURNING OUR NEXT ITEM IS AB
FIFTY SEVEN BY SEVEN MEMBER
GABRIEL IT IS THE- SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AND HE IS WAY
PRESENTATION. THIS IS ON. LAW
ENFORCEMENT HATE CRIMES IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THROUGH WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY
SEVEN. SIGNAL TURN TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. I SEE NO
WITNESSES THERE SO MODERATOR
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHICH THE TEST FIVE YEAR
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY SEVEN. SHOW
SUPPORT FOR AB FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI FIVE
SEVEN. NOBODY IS COMING UP AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR VERY
GOOD LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCEDURE FOR THE OPPOSITION
OTHER WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE WHICH THE
TESTIFIED. IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FIFTY SEVEN MISTER GRAHAM YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
SENATOR BY KHALKHIN MEMBERS
MARK GRAHAM IN SUPPORT AND ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
SUPPORT THE PRESERVATION OF
LOCAL ZONING AUTHORITY OVER THE
PLACEMENT OF CELL ANTENNAS.
CONSISTENT WITH FORTY SEVEN U.
S. C. SECTION THREE THREE TO
SEE FROM THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ACT OF NINETEEN NINETY SIX AND
WE ARE OPPOSED. THANKS VERY
MUCH MR GAVIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. S. THANK YOU CENTRO
CASKEY I'M PAUL THE GUY WITH
CALIFORNIANS WHO DO READ THE
NINETEEN NINETY SIX TOLD THE
CASE THAT CAREFULLY AND WE
ABIDE BY SECTION THREE TO FOUR
THAT SAYS IN ALL CIRCUMSTANCES
ALL RADIO LIGHTS THE BY THE FCC
MUST USE THE MINIMUM POWER FOR
THE COMMUNICATION DESIRED THAT
WOULD BE MINUS EIGHTY FIVE DBM
AND WE OPPOSE THE BILL. SEEING
NO OTHER WITNESSES HEARD
WITNESSES HERE AND ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE RETURN TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY I SEE NO WITNESSES
HERE AND TEST WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION SO
MODERATOR. PLEASE Q. MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR PURSUE WHICH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR BY TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR
A. B. FIVE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FILED
BY ZERO. TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
AB FIFTY SEVEN AND WE WILL NINE
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
SIXTY THREE. SACRAMENTO GERMAN
BIRDS- GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF
OF DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WE'RE ACTUALLY IN. SUPPORT OF
THE FRAZIER THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT. L. AS A FINAL REMINDER
FOR OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND NOBODY ELSE IS
QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR-
COULDN'T CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING
LET'S CHECK WITH THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCED- MISS ON THE DERA
YOU'RE ON THE SAME LINE. IF I
WAS TO HEAR VERY GOOD SEEING NO
MEMBERS OF THE- COMMITTEE PUT
THEIR HANDS UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIFTY SEVEN IS
MOVED TO SUSPENSE FILE. NEXT UP
WE HAVE A SEVEN MEMBER ROBERT
RIVAS IS HEALTH EMERGENCIES
REGARDING SMOKE HIS WAY
PRESENTATION THIS IS A
CANDIDATE FOR OUR SUSPENSE FILE
SO LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO THREE WHICH THE
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTY THREE SEEING NONE WILL
TURN TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY ODD
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC EYE SEEN NONE. SO
LET'S TURN TO THE TELUS
CONFERENCE SERVICE IN.
MODERATOR OR WILL YOU PLEASE
PROP ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF AB
SEVENTY THREE. THE TESTIFYING
SUPPORT FOR A SEVENTY THREE-
EXCUSE ME AB SEVEN THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND NOBODY IS
KILLING UP MISTER CHAIR. VERY
GOOD LET'S FALL THE SAME-
PROCEDURE FOR OPPOSITION IS ANY
WITNESSES HERE MA'AM FORTY TWO
OR THREE WHO WAS TESTIFYING
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTY THREE
MISTER GRAHAM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU SENATOR
AKAKA MEMBERS MARKRAM ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIANS WHO KNOWS THAT
THE STATE IS ON ABLE. TO
GUARANTEE THAT IT WILL ENSURE
SAFETY IF IT EXPANDS THE
PLACEMENT OF CELL ANTENNAS ON
CITY STREETS AND CLOSE TO HOME.
AND WE ARE OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
MR KEVIN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU CENTER CASKEY MINUS
PALM AGAIN WITH CALIFORNIANS
WHO RECOGNIZE THAT MANY CITIES
IN CALIFORNIA FROM TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE HAVE PASSED PROTECTIVE
WIRELESS ORDINANCES TO ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE ACTUAL PUBLIC
SAFETY AND THE QUIET ENJOYMENT
OF THEIR STREETS IN THE
RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOODS AND
WE OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SINGLE OTHER
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE WILL TURN TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY I SEE NO
WITNESSES. WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO AB SEVENTY
THREE SO MODERATOR- VIA THE
TELEPHONE CONFERENCE SERVICE
CAN YOU SEE IF ANY WITNESSES
ARE ON THE LINE TO TESTIFY. IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTY THREE.
EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR A. B.
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE FILED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP
COULDN'T CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING
CHECKED WITH THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCED MISSED ON A DEREK DO
YOU HAVE A FILE ON AB SEVENTY
THREE. THE FILE MISTER CHAIR
VERY BIG MEMBERS ARE COLLEAGUES
ON THE DAY HAS SEEING NO. HAN
SERVE WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
SEVENTY THREE IS MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. NEXT UP WE HAVE
AB SEVEN NINETEEN WHICH IS THE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEES- MEASURE
ON DIS- THE COMMITTEE HAS
WAIVED- PRESENTATION AWARDS
CHAIR MISTER RIVAS'S WAY
PRESENTATION IT IS A CANDIDATE
FOR SUSPENSE. IS SO WE'LL MOVE
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO THREE
WHICH THE TESTS FIND SUPPORT OF
AB SEVEN ONE NINE. SEEING THEN
I'LL CHECK IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
EIGHT THERE ARE NO WITNESSES
THERE IN SUPPORT SO MODERATE
PLEASE QUEUE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN ONE NINE.
FEET A TELECONFERENCING SERVICE.
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO TESTIFY TO
HAVE SOMEBODY KILLING UP ONE
MOMENT. FINE MOTOR STRUCTURE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO LINE ONE OH
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT- TO
YOUR OPEN. FIND ONE OR TWO CAN
YOU HEAR. YES MARTIN DOCUMENTS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BEEKEEPERS SPONSORING THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT. AND IF THERE
ANY OTHER PARTICIPANTS- QUEUING
UP OR WOULD LIKE TO QUEUE UP
FOR A. B. SEVEN ONE NINE TO
SHOW THEIR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE'RE
HAVING NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUE UP AT THIS TIME. IT DOES
FALL THE SAME PROCESS FOR A
POSITION WITH THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HERE. IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVEN ONE NINE. MISTER GRAHAM
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU.
SENATOR Y. CASKET MEMBERS
MARKRAM ON BEHALF OF ELK GROVE
RESIDENTS WHO APPRECIATE. THAT
OUR CITY CURRENTLY PROHIBITS
THE PLACEMENT OF CELL ANTENNAS.
IMMEDIATELY ADJACENT TO THE
FRONT YARD OF A RESIDENTIAL
DWELLING. AND WE DO NOT WANT
THE STATE TO OVERRIDE OUR
LOCAL. ZONING CODE AND WE ARE
CLOSED. THANK YOU. MR DEVIN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED IN OPPOSITION OF
AB SEVEN ONE NINE. I'M ORRY TO
BE OUT OF ORDER BUT ON BEES I
HAVE TO SUPPORT AND THAT IS
BECAUSE WE ARE AWARE OF A CELL
TOWER TURNED ON IN IDAHO
LITERALLY A HUNDRED FEET FROM
HANK ALLEN'S BACKYARD THEY
KILLED EVERYONE OF HIS BEES IN
AS BEEHIVE. ENTERS VIDEO
EVIDENCE TO PROVE IT. VERY
SENSITIVE TO THIS WE
APPRECIATE. TAKE CARE OF OUR
ENVIRONMENT WE OPPOSE WE
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
SO NOTED BUT SEVENTEEN AWARDED
WITNESSES HERE WILL TURN TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SIX YEARS
WITNESSES THE PUBLIC WHICH NAY
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVEN NINETEEN I SEE NONE
SALUTE MODERATE LET'S TURN TO
WITNESSES WILLING TO. HER
WANTING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEES AB SEVEN ONE NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND HE
SAID TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR
AB SEVEN NINETEEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE FELL BY ZERO. THE
BATHROOMS WE HAVE NO
PARTICIPANT QUEUING UP MISTER
CHAIR. PART WAS THAT SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION OPPOSITION YEAH
OPPOSITION'S DONE SO WE ARE ON
A. B. SEVEN NINETEENTH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DO YOU
HAVE A FILE. MISTER CHAIR YES
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE ESTIMATES THE
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD RESULTING
FROM THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY. I'M
GOING FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
ALSO DUE TO THE INCLUSION OF
ADDITIONAL PENALTIES FOR HONEY
LABELLING. THE DEPARTMENT CITES
THE NEED FOR AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND TO CREATE A HONEY
LABELLING PROGRAM. ALL RIGHT TO
COME BACK TO COMMITTEE SEEING
NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SEVEN NINETEEN.
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
AB ONE EIGHT ONE ONE EIGHT BY
COM LONGER ON EMERGENCY
SERVICES GRANT PROGRAM. IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION. WILL GO RIGHT
TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. NOBODY
HERE. NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
TO ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE ONE EIGHT.
SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB ONE ONE
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE FILED
BY ZERO. AND WE WERE LINE SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
GREGORY. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE ANOTHER
ONE QUEUING UP. THE WITH THIS
MOMENTARILY NINE NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
SHALL WE DO VERY ON BEHALF OF-THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE ONE EIGHT.
TWENTY ONE IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED.
THE GENTLEMAN IF YOU COULD CAN
KEEP KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO THE
FISCAL ASPECTS THAT WOULD BE
GREAT. QUIET BERMAN SENATOR
PORTANTINO NUMBERS. MARKRAM HI
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE OPPOSED. YOUR MAKING POLICY
WITHOUT CONSIDERING THE
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE BECAUSE IT
WILL RAISE THE COSTS TO THE
STATE BOTH IN TERMS OF A
MEDICAL COSTS FOR PEOPLE THAT
ARE INJURED AND LITIGATION AND
WE'RE OPPOSED. ALL RIGHT.
PLEASE REVENUE GENTLEMAN LOTS
OF LEEWAY TODAY SHOW. THANK YOU
SENATOR PORTANTINO- I WORK WITH
CALIFORNIANS TO SUPPORT THE-
THE CONCLUSION THAT THIS IS A
LIABILITY TRANSFERRED TO CITIES
TO ALLOW CELL TOWERS IN THE
PUBLIC RIGHTS OF WAY AND WE
OPPOSE THE BILL. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
NOBODY THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE. OPPOSED AB ONE ONE
EIGHT. TO OPPOSITION FOR AB ONE
ONE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO FOR AB ONE ONE EIGHT.
AND NOBODY IS KILLING UP MISTER
CHAIR RIGHT BERMAN FINANCE EVER
FILE. FILE THIS YEAR- FILE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
ONE ONE EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON A. B. NINE
SIX TWO. ON RETURNABLE BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS BY SENATOR OR
SENATOR KAMLAGER. THE AUTHORS
WAVE SUSPENSE- WAY PRESENTATION
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE.
MOVED TO SUPPORT ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE.
THE MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
NOBODY THEIR- MODERATOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE SUPPORTING AB
NINE SIX TWO. EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI NINE SIX TWO
NINE SIX TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WILL THE
LINE ONE OF THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
NUMBER MATALIN COOPER WITH
NIELSEN WORK ON BEHALF OF MARIN
COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND AS A FINAL REMINDER TO SHOW
EXT- SKEWS ME SUPPORT FOR A BI
NINETY SIX TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. I KNOW
WHETHER PARTICIPANTS ARE
QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION.
OF AB NINE SIX TWO WERE IN THIS
ROOM. GERMAN AGAIN CONFINED
YOUR COMMENTS TO FISH YOUR
ORGANIZATION TO OFFICIAL. AND
BE BRIEF IF YOU MAY THANK YOU.
CERTAINLY TURN PORTANTINO ON
MEMBERS MARKRAM ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO BELIEVE THAT A
CELL ANTENNA ON PUBLIC PROPERTY
IS A DANGEROUS CONDITION ON
PUBLIC PROPERTY IN CALIFORNIA
LAW IMPOSES LIABILITY FOR THAT
AND THAT WOULD BE IT. IN ENTAIL
HUGE COSTS FOR THE STATE AND
CITIES AND WE'RE OPPOSED. THANK
YOU SIR PORTANTINO MAIS PUBLIC
AVENUE WE'RE CALIFORNIANS WHO
AGREE WITH THE TOPIC TURNS IN
UNITED STATES INCLUDING SCOTT
KNOW THAT FROM THE FCC THAT THE
SEPTEMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
AT FIFTEEN ORDER EIGHTEEN DASH
ONE THREE THREE THIS
PRESUMPTIVE ONLY IT'S NOT
FEDERAL LAW AND SHOULD NOT
BECOME STATE LAW. WE OPPOSE THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT MOVING ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SHOWING NOBODY
THEIR MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED A. B. NINE
SIX TWO. EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR
AB NINE SIX TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE FILED BY ZERO. NOBODY
IS QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION. FINANCIALLY HAVE A
FILE. YES THIS BILL MAY RESULT
IN COST ABOUT TWO ONE MILLION
DOLLARS BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING FUND AND SEVEN
POSITIONS ON GOING FOR CAL
RECYCLE TO IMPLEMENT THIS BILL.
ALL RIGHT WE HEARD FROM FINANCE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION THING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION.
A. B. NINE SIX TWO WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON A. B. TWO
TWO ONE SANTIAGO ON EMERGENCY
FOOD ASSISTANCE. YEAH IT'S A
SURPRISE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WEEK PRESENTATION. WE'LL GO
RIGHT TO SUPPORT. TWENTY ONE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE SING
NOBODY NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO TWO ONE. YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO TWO ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE WERE LINE TWENTY
SIX YOU ARE OPEN. AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TO PAMELA
GIVES REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND WE SUPPORT AB TWO
TWO ONE. M. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTY TWO OR FOR ANYBODY
ELSE TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI
TWO TWO ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
SIXTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO
COREY WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES CALLING IN
SUPPORT. I KNOW I THE
PARTICIPANTS ARGUED OUT MISTER
CHAIR. ALL RIGHT I WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO TO ONE IN
THIS ROOM. PLEASE KEEP YOUR
ORGANIZATIONNAME BRIEF AND
FISCAL. BERMAN SENATOR
PORTANTINO ON MEMBERS MARKRAM
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE OPPOSED TO CREATING
POTENTIALLY MANY MANY NEW
LAWSUIT IN CALIFORNIA SUPERIOR
COURT OVER CITIES HAVING TO-
TAKE THE CARRIERS TO COURT OVER
THE DEEMED APPROVED CELL
ANTENNA PERMITS AND WE'RE
OPPOSED. THANK YOU SENATE
FORTINO PALMA GAVAN
CALIFORNIANS WHO I SPEAK TO FCC
TOURNEY'S EVERY SIX MONTHS AND
WE KNOW THAT THE DEFINITION OF
A SMALL CELL HAS NO FOUNDATION
BECAUSE IT WAS. WIPED OUT IN
AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
AND WE OPPOSE THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT LET'S MOVE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THERE'S NOBODY THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB. TWO TWO ONE. THE
SHOW OPPOSITION FOR A B. TWO
TWO ONE WE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE ONE ZERO TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS MARKET OFF
THE BENCH ON BEHALF OF- IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO TO ONE I'M
SORRY FOR CALLING IN LIGHT
THANK YOU. NO WORRIES IN IT TO
SHOW OPPOSITION FOR- AB TWO TWO
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUING
UP MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT FINANCES THEIR FILE.
YOU. NO FILE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWO TWO
ONE MOVES TO SUSPENSE MOVING AB
FOUR FIVE SEVEN BY SANTIAGO ON
PROTECTION OF PATIENT CHOICE IN
TELEHEALTH. HI THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT
TO SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. TWENTY ONE IN
ROOM TWENTY EXCUSE ME THERE'S
NO ONE AROUND FORTY TWO OH
THREE IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY NO BOUNDARIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR FIVE SEVEN.
EXPRESS US SUPPORT FOR A BI FOR
FIVE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FILED BY
ZERO FOR A. B. FOUR FIVE SEVEN.
BY NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS SHALL WE DO VERY
WITH THAT CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES AND SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO FOR SUPPORT ON. EIGHTY
FOUR FIVE SEVEN. THE
PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUING UP
MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR FIVE
SEVEN GO AHEAD. BERMAN
PORTANTINO ONE MEMBERS MARKRAM
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
REMEMBER THAT ON TWO OCCASIONS
THE FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS
COMMISSION DECLINED TO ADOPT A
DEEMED APPROVED FOR CELL
ANTENNA PERMITS AND THAT.
AVOIDED CLOGGING UP THE
CALIFORNIA COURTS WITH LAWSUITS
AND WE'RE OPPOSED. ALL RIGHT
NEXT PERSON. THANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO PALMER GOT WITH
CALIFORNIANS WHO KNOW FROM
THOSE SEC ATTORNEYS THAT EVERY
WIRELESS TELECOM FACILITY OF
ANY SIZE OR ANY G. MUST UNDERGO
NATIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
REVIEW AND THOSE THAT DO NOT
WHICH IS ALMOST ALL OF THEM
THEY CAN LOSE THEIR LICENSE IF
THEY DON'T. WE OPPOSE THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT MOVING ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THERE'S NOBODY THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB FOUR. FIVE SEVEN. TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR A. B.
FOUR FIVE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE FELL
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO PARTICIPANTS
QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT HAVEN'T
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
FAMILY STRUCTURE- FILE SEEING
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB FOUR FIVE SEVEN. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON AB FIVE
SEVENTY BY SANTIAGO.
INDEPENDENT PARENT HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE- THIS IS A SENSE RENTS
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT TO
SUPPORT. THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM SUPPORTING ANYONE A ROOM
TWENTY FORTY KNOW ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE SEVENTY. THANKS PRESS-
SUPPORT FOR AB FIVE SEVEN ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE FILED BY
ZERO. NOBODY IS QUEUING UP
MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION OF AB. FIVE
SEVENTY. THANK YOU SENATOR
PORTANTINO ON MEMBERS MARKRAM
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
EXPERIENCED HEADACHES INSOMNIA
AND TONIGHT IS IN THEIR HOMES
FROM INVOLUNTARY EXPOSURE TO
ELECTROMAGNETIC FIELDS AND WE
ARE OPPOSED. CENTER PORTANTINO
PALMA GAVIN FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE FCC
REGULATES ONLY TITLE TO
SERVICES WHICH IS
TELECOMMUNICATIONS NOT TITLE
ONE SERVICES WHICH IS WIRELESS
BROADBAND AND THEREFORE THEY
HAVE NO RIGHTS TO BE IN THE
PUBLIC RIGHTS WAY WE OPPOSE THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB FIVE
SEVEN. EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR
AB FIVE SEVEN ZERO PLEASE TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY. ZERO NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT WE TAKE IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAVE A FILE. IN FACT
THIS YEAR NO FILE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE
SEVENTY. GOES TO SUSPENSE AB
TWO FIVE SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA ON CRIMINAL PROCEDURE.
THE DISCRIMINATION THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE EASIEST WAY
PRESENTATION. OF A RIGHT TO
SUPPORT TESTIMONY THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATE OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO FIVE SIX. EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWO FIVE SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. BILL COUPLE QUEUEING UP
FOR BILL'S GOING AT ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME FOR. A SUPPORT ON AB
TWO FIVE SIX Y. NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
SHALL WE DO VERY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT OF THE
SPELLS THANK YOU. YOUR NEXT- WE
WILL GO TO. LINE SIXTY THREE
YOU ARE OPEN. RETURN MEMBERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO FIFTY SIX
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN THE SUPPORT LET'S GO TO
OPPOSITION NOW. OF AB TWO FIVE
SIX. NUMBER OF. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MARKRAM ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO BELIEVE IS A
STE HI MATTER OF STATE INTEREST
TO PRESERVE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING AND THAT THAT SHOULD BE A
HIGHER PRIORITY THAN ANY
PARTICULAR METHOD OF PROVIDING
HIGH SPEED INTERNET. AND WE ARE
OPPOSED. THANK YOU SIR
PORTANTINO PALMA GAVIN AND WITH
CALIFORNIANS WHO UNDERSTAND F.
T. T. P. IS THE SOLUTION IT
MEANS TWO THINGS FIBER OPTIC TO
THE PROMISES AND FREEDOM TO THE
PEOPLE THAT IS THE WAY TO CLOSE
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. IN AN
EFFORT TO REACH A WORKABLE WAY
IN CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT MOVING ON ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY
THERE IS ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED AB TWO FIVE SIX.
BEGIN ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO
SHOW OPPOSITION ONE FOLLOWED BY.
ZERO THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
INTERVIEWING MR. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE HAVE A FILE. I FOUND
THE STRUCTURE WE HAVE NO FILE-
WE WILL GO TO MY COLLEAGUES SEE
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWO FIVE SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WE HAVE ALREADY DONE
AB TWO SEVEN NINE BY MR MARC SU
CHI SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
AB TWO EIGHT SEVEN BY MISTER
CORE WHICH IS ON CIVIL ACTIONS
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE HE'S WAY
PRESENTATION. AND WE'LL GO
RIGHT TO TESTIMONY SUPPORTERS
NOMINEE ROOM TO FORTY TWO OH
THREE THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WATER IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO EIGHT SEVEN.
ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ONCE AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE
QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE TAKEN THE SUPPORT
NOW LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION AB
TWO EIGHT SEVEN GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU SENATOR PORTANTINO MARKRAM
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
BELIEVE THIS BILL IS
UNNECESSARY IT'S PUNITIVE AND
THE STATE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
COMMENCE THESE LAWSUITS WITHIN
THE CURRENT STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS WHICH IS ONE YEAR
OTHERWISE YOU'RE GOING TO
CREATE MORE UNNECESSARY LAW ALL
RIGHT. I GOT OPPOSE THANK YOU.
GENENA GIVEN YOU A LOT OF
LEEWAY TODAY SO PLEASE
RECIPROCATE BY BEING PRE FOR
THANK YOU. PORTANTINO THANK YOU
SO MUCH- WE- WILL TO ADDRESS WE
ARE CALIFORNIANS WHO KNOW THAT-
PHD IN PHYSICS AS MR CORK IS-
BURKE DR QUIRK- HAS NO
CREDENTIALS TO MAKE ANY
STATEMENTS ON ANIME FIFTY AND
WE REFRAIN FROM REFERENCING TO
THE AUTHOR. AND THE BRIEF THANK
YOU WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. THING NOBODY THEIR
MODERATOR ANYBODY OPPOSED AB.
TWO EIGHT SEVEN. IN SHORT
POSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW FOR US
ONCE AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY.
ZERO PICTURED HERE WITH NO ONE
COMING UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT UNDERTAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION GOING PART IN A
FINANCES THEIR FILE IN AB TWO
EIGHT SEVEN. THE FAMILY
STRUCTURE NO FILE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWO EIGHT
SEVEN GO TO SUSPEND. LEVINE AB
THREE OH FIVE BY MAIENSCHEIN
VETERAN SERVICES NOTICE.
SUSPEND CANDIDATE OFFERS WAY
PRESENTATION. WITH A PUBLIC
TEST POINT SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. FOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF. AB THREE OH
FIVE. ONCE AGAIN SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ONCE AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. WE HAVE NO LINE'S QUEUING
AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF
AB THREE OH FIVE AGAIN PLEASE
BE BRIEF. DEATH THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN PORTANTINO AND MEMBERS
MARKRAM THE GRAND FINALE WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE TODAY
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE ON THESE BILLS
AND WE'RE OPPOSED. THANK YOU. I
THANK YOU PAUL MCGOVERN- WOULD
CALIFORNIA'S RECOGNIZES SENATOR
PORTANTINO AND SENATOR CASKEY
ARE SCHOLARS AND GENTLEMEN AND
WE APPRECIATE YOU LISTENING AND
GIVING US THE LEEWAY YOU DID
TODAY WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
IT WE OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GENTLEMAN. ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY NOBODY THERE. MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB THREE OH FIVE.
INITIAL OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONCE AGAIN
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. SURE NO
LINE'S QUEUING AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE TAKE
ITS FOREIGN OPPOSITION WE GO TO
MISANO DERA AND FINANCE. THE
PHARMACY ARE PROFILE SEE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
THREE OH FIVE. TO MOVE TO
SUSPENSE FOR MOVING ON THE A.
B. THREE FORTY BY FAMILY MEMBER
WARD ON GOLDEN STATE
SCHOLARHIP SCHOLAR SHARE
TRUST. SUSPENSE CANDID AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO TO
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. SO MANY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE FORTY. TO
SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIND SIXTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. COLQUITT
WITH THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES CALLING IN SUPPORT.
YOU KNOW FOR THE LINE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION AND THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
WILL BOTH THE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB THREE
FORTY. ONCE AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO TO SHOW OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND WE SHOULD KNOW LIKE
TO QUEUE MISTER CARE. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE FORTY
SEEN NO HANDS GO UP- SHOULD BE
MODERATE ASKED ME DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YOU HAVE A FILE. MISTER
CHAIR THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
ESTIMATES GENERAL FUND REVENUE
LOSSES OF ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO. AND ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. WE DO
NOT ANTICIPATE THIS BILL WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT FTP SAID
MINISTRY OF COSTS. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES AND SEEING NO
QUESTIONS- HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THREE FORTY. WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE BROWN AB THREE
SEVEN FIVE FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
EMPLOYEES SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION-
WILL GO TO SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY HERE THERE'S NO MANY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. WATER IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE SEVEN
FIVE. AND TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO BUT AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. WE ARE SHOWING NO LINES
KILLING AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MATTERS OR ANYONE
OPPOSED AB THREE SEVEN FIVE ON
THE PHONE LINE. CAN ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. OR OPPOSITION
ONE OF THE BY ZERO. THANKS. YOU
HAVE NO LINES IN OPPOSITION
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION- THIR FILE MS ON
AND THEIR FAMILIES ARE HERE NO
FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THREE SEVEN FIVE
AGO TO SUSPENSE LIVING ON THE
THREE EIGHT EIGHT MEDINA
CERTIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
AGAIN IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATIONS- WE
WILL GO RIGHT TO SUPPORT
TESTIMONY REPORTED TO A THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE HOW MANY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
SUPPORTING AB THREE EIGHT
EIGHT. SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE
DO HAVE SEVERAL AND KILLING AT
THE MOMENT TO BE JUST ONE
MOMENT. FIRST WE HAVE LINE
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYBODY THERE. NINE SIXTY IS
DISCONNECTED NEXT WE HAVE ONE
ONE ZERO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MICHELLE COHEN ADULT EDUCATION
TEACHER FROM LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT CALLING
IN SUPPORT. NEXT WE HAVE LINE
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS AMY DOES ONE
I'VE BEEN A TEACHER AT GRANT
HIGH SCHOOL IN LOS ANGELES FOR
FOURTEEN YEARS WITHOUT
PERMANENT STATUS I SUPPORT.
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY EIGHT.
THANKS TO HAVE ONE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THE
STANDARD CARLO WITH L. A. U. S.
D. DIVISION OF ADULT AND CAREER
EDUCATION MY TWENTY SEVEN YEAR
VETERAN WHO'S ENJOYED PERMANENT
STATUS IT'S MADE ME A BETTER
TEACHER AND I SUPPORT AB. THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT. THANKS WE'VE LINE
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS CARL PORTER- OF A
LONG TIME- ADULT A TEACHER WITH
L. A. U. S. B. DIVISION OF
ADULT AND CAREER EDUCATION AND
I SUPPORT PERMANENT STATUS. OF
AB. THREE EIGHTY EIGHT. FIND
ONE HUNDRED. YES MY NAME IS
CAPTAIN VALENZUELA AND I
SUPPORT EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT I AM THIRTY ONE YEARS
WITH L. A. YOU AS BEING DAYS.
AND I DO SUPPORT THIS BILL ALL
SPEAKING INSTRUCTORS PLEASE
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS LIEUTENANT.
HELLO MY NAME IS NOT AN
UNFAMILIAR AND I AM UNABLE TO
LOCATE A LOW IDEA FEATURING
FIFTY FOR THE PAST SEVENTEEN
YEARS WITH ALL- WITHOUT
REQUIRING A PERMANENT STATUS
PLEASE CONSIDER THE LENGTH OF
THE FUTURE- PLEASE VOTING OF
THE POOR OF AB THREE EIGHTY.
THANK. FIND ONE HUNDRED AND
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. OF THE
PROJECT MYRA THIRTY LEVEL
VETERAN WITH. THE HELPING
PEOPLE GET THEIR ARTICLE THE
PROBLEM WAS- A PLEASE SUPPORT-
THIS BILL THANK YOU. FIND ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ARGHA
FAMINE CENTER THIRTEEN THAT OUR
TEACHERS FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
FIVE YEARS I SUPPORT THE DEAL.
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT. ONCE AGAIN
JUST A REMINDER THIS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT. MR HERE AT THIS TIME
WE'RE SHOWING NO FOR THE LINES
IN Q. ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE EIGHT
EIGHT- THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM IS OPEN IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE. OPPOSED AB.
THREE EIGHT EIGHT. CHAU
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW FOR US
ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW OPPOSITION.
RESPONSE ONE FOLLOWED BY. ZERO
FIRST WE HAVE ONE ONE ONE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH MY NAME
IS KEVIN JORDAN AND I'M A
TEACHER AND L. A. U. S. TEAM IN
ADULT EDUCATION TEACHER- AND I
ASK YOU TO PLEASE REPORT AB
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT FOR
PERMANENT STATUS FOR ALL YEAH.
MY NAME IS. INSTRUMENTED SHOW
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. EXT WE HAVE
LINE SEVENTY FOUR. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS BRENDAN
FAILING ON BEHALF OF AND VOICE
IN OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME
WE'RE SHOWING NO FOR THE LINE
THINK YOU MISTER CRE ALL RIGHT
WOULD TAKE IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION GO TO FINANCE. THEIR
FILE MISTER CHAIR NO FILE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
THREE EIGHT EIGHT COSTA
SUSPENSE AB ONE ONE ONE THREE
MEDINA ON PUBLIC POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
WAY PRESENTATION WITH ALL RIGHT
TO SUPPORT. TESTIMONY THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO WHICH
TO ME TWENTY FORTY MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN. THIRTEEN
SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO BUT AGAIN ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NO POINT
DOING AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR
ALL RIGHT WHAT OPPOSITION OF AB
ELEVEN THIRTEEN THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY MATTER IS OR
ANYONE OPPOSED AB ELEVEN
THIRTEEN. IN ON THE PHONE LINE.
BUT AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
TO SHOW OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO LAND
KILLING FOR SPORT MISTER CHAIR
OR OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT WE DID
WE DID WE DID OPPOSITION NO.
WELL LET'S JUST GO THROUGH
ANYBODY OPPOSE IN THIS ROOM IN
THAT ROOM NO NOBODY TWENTY
FORTIES NOBODY'S ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED OR OR SUPPORT OF
ELEVEN THIRTEEN. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL MOVE. QUESTIONS ARE
ACTUALLY FINANCED THE OF IS A
FILE. IF I AM A TEACHER NO FILE
NO QUESTIONS THAT OBJECTION A.
B. ELEVEN THIRTEEN GOES TO
SUSPENSE AB THREE NINETY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES ON
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE-
SUSPENSE CAN EIGHT AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM FOR THE PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE'S NO MINIMUM
TWENTY FORTY FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. BONNER'S OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE NINE SEVEN. SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO NOW FOR US ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. FIRST WE HAVE LINE SIXTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. INDICIA
SUPPORTERS ONE FOLLOWED BY.
ZERO NEXT WE HAVE LINE ONE ONE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. POKER
WITH THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES CALLING IN SUPPORT.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE SEVEN NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR MY NAME IS
AND HE DOES THAT MEAN YOU'RE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE CENTRE
FOR WORKERS RIGHT. THE PART OF
AB THREE NINETY SEVEN. NO FOR
THE LINE TO SUPPORT MISTER
CHAIR I WOULD OPPOSITION OF AB
THREE NINE SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM. FAMILY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB. THREE SEVEN SEVEN
THREE NINE SEVEN. CHAU
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONCE AGAIN FOR
OPPOSITION ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
WE SHOULD KNOW LINES AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE HAVE A FILE. I FOUND
THIS YEAR NO FILE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB THREE
NINETY SEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE LIVING ON AB FOUR OH
TWO BY SEVEN MEMBER WICKS ON
THE OFFICE OF CLIMATE ADVOCATE
ENDS STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY GROUP-
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
WILL GO RIGHT INTO PUBLIC
COMMENT. THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM IN SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MINORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR OH TWO. TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI FOUR ZERO
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE OTHER
PARTY'S BEEN QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT. I WILL GO TO LINE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SEVENTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN.
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE ON MUTE.
NOW WE ARE HAVING ONLY SENATORS
AGAIN MY NAME IS EDDIE GOT THAT
MANUAL CALLING ON BEHALF CENTER
FOR WORKERS RIGHTS THE BOARD OF
AB FOUR OKAY. THANKS WE WILL TO
A LINE ONE ZERO SIX FOR ANYBODY
ELSE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A
BEFORE TO. INSPIRED ME ONE OF
THEM WITH THE OTHER CALLING
FROM LEGAL. WORK IN SUPPORT OF
AB FOUR YEAH THANK YOU. AND
THERE ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
GIVING UP THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT LET'S GOOD OPPOSITION
OF AB FOUR OH TWO THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM. NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE. OPPOSED AB.
FOUR OH TWO. TO OPPOSITION FOR
A BEFORE- TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY GENERAL. ONE FELL
BY ZERO. WE HAVE NO PARTICIPANT
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION- MODEL-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE A
FILE. FILE NO FILE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION MAYBE FOR A
TWO AGO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
THE AB FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS ON SEXUAL
ASSAULT BY LAW ENFORCEMENT. A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION AND WE'LL GO
TO PUBLIC COMMENT ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE THERE'S NOBODY
HERE THERE'S NO MAIN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. WATER IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
FIVE. EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR A
BI FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. N.
AGAIN FOR SUPPORT FOR A BI
FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE
HAVE NOBODY QUEUEING UP AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
FIVE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM. THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MONTEREY OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE. EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WILL GO TO FINANCE.
FILE A FILE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY FIVE GOES TO SUSPENSE.
MOVIE ON AB FOUR THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON ON DEBT
DEBT COLLECTION IDENTITY THEFT.
SUSPENSE CAN EIGHT AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE.
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATE IS FOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE SUPPORT OF A
BABY FOR THIRTY. THE SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI FOUR THIRTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND NOBODY IS GIVING UP.
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT OPPOSITION OF
AB FOUR THIRTY THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO
AB. FOR THIRTY. EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR AB FOUR THIRTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NOBODY
QUEUEING UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WILL GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WELL
MISTER CHAIR NO FILED NO
QUESTIONS ABOUT OBJECTION IT
BEFORE THIRTY GOES TO SUSPENSE
A BEFORE THIRTY EIGHT. BY SEVEN
NUMBER RAMOS ON SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE
LAYOFF NOTICE HEARINGS. THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION WITH ALL RIGHT
PUBLIC. TESTIMONY SUPPORTERS
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR'S ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT. THE SUPPORT
FOR A BI FOR THREE EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
WE WILL BEGIN WITH WINE ONE
TWENTY ONE FOR ANYBODY ELSE
GOING HIT ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
FOR A BI FOUR THREE EIGHT. ONE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
YES IT SHERMAN BEIJING
SENTIMENT I APOLOGIZE I WAS
TRYING TO CALL EARLIER IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT AND I WAS NOT ABLE TO GET
THROUGH ELLIS YOU'RE TELL US
YOUR NAME AS HER. MY NAME IS
STEVEN ROTHBLATT ALL RIGHT HE
SAID EVANS COMMUNITY ADULT
SCHOOL. AND I DO SUPPORT OF AB
HAS EIGHTY NINE POINT THREE
SUPPORT AB THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
CHRISTO'S COURTESY DO NOT HAVE
TEN AFTER MIDNIGHT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO
BACK TO BEFORE THIRTY EIGHT.
OKAY TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A
BI FOR THIRTY EIGHT- PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE
ONE TWENTY YOU ARE UP. TULARE
WITH THE MERICAN FEDERATION
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES CALLING IN SUPPORT.
AND WE HAVE ONE OTHER
PARTICIPANT THAT IS QUEUING UP.
BEAR WITH US ONE MOMENT MISTER
CHAIR. M. BY ONE NINETEEN YOUR
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS TO OUR
STORY AND CHLORIDES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION WERE CO SPONSORS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP
THANKS I WILL GO TO A POSITION
OF AB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED AB FOUR THREE
EIGHT. YOU ARE OPPOSED TO A
BEFORE THREE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR COULD CREATE COST IN THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO CONFORM
THE LAYOUT PROCESS FOR NON
CERTIFICATED EMPLOYEES TO THE
NON REELECTION PROCESS FOR
CERTIFICATED IN ACADEMIC
EMPLOYEES ADDITIONALLY WHAT'S
UNKNOWN. THE NEW NON REELECTION
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS WILL
COST ELEAZAR THIS BILL WOULD
MORE THAN DOUBLE THE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES ENTITLED TO THESE
NOTIFICATIONS AND THE HEARING
PROCESS. SHOULD THE COMMISSION
STATE MANDATES DETERMINE THESE
CHANGES TO BE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE BECAUSE-
INDICATOR TWELVE AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE MANDATE BLOCK GRANT
PROGRAMS. ALL RIGHT WE'VE HEARD
FROM FINANCE WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
FOR THIRTY EIGHT- WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE WILL MOVE ON TO AB FOR
SEVENTY BY SEVEN MEMBER FOR RIO
ON MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY. WILL
GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT- AND
STARTED FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE. WILL GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE- WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE ANYBODY IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOUR SEVENTY. SHOWS
SUPPORT FOR A BI FOR SEVENTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AB. FOUR SEVENTY. ONE
MOMENT WE HAVE ONE NINE WITH AN
OPERATOR. AND LINE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS ERIC
GLORIA MAY HAVE TO THE CALIBERS
RETIREMENT SAVINGS FORWARD IN
SUPPORT. MISTER NOBODY ELSE'S
QUEUED UP NO ONE ELSE IS QUEUED
UP TO GO TO OPPOSITION OF AB
FOUR SEVENTY THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY MODERATES ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB FOUR
SEVENTY. BUT SHALL OPPOSITION
FOR AB FOUR SEVEN ZERO PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY. ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AB FOUR SEVENTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. NOBODY HAS
QUEUED UP MISTER CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE HEARDFROM SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WILL GO TO FARMING
TO FINANCE. FILE THIS YEAR-
FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A BEFORE SEVENTY GOES
TO SUSPENSE AB FOUR EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN ON
CHARITABLE ORGANIZATIONS. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION. AND
WE'LL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM SHOULD KNOWN IN TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE- THAT IS. SUPPORTIVE
OF AB. FOUR EIGHT EIGHT. TO
SUPPORT FOR AB FOUR EIGHT EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. WE HAVE ONE QUEUING UP
ONE MOMENT ANYBODY ELSE THINK
THIS OPPORTUNITY AND HIT ONE
FILED BY ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR A BI FOUR EIGHT EIGHT NINE
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS ANTHONY LIEU ON BEHALF
OF ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB BONTA
WHERE THE FUNDS ARE OF EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT- THE BILL.
PROVIDES NEEDED OVERSIGHT OF
CHARITABLE FUNDRAISING ON
INTERNET PLATFORMS THANK YOU.
KNOW WHETHER PARTICIPANTS ARE
QUEUED UP ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHT THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S NO
MINIMUM TWENTY FORTY. THREE ONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB
FOUR EIGHT EIGHT. PLEASE
EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR AB FOUR
EIGHT EIGHT AT THIS TIME BY
PRESSING ONE ZERO. SO PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION GO TO
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. NO FILE NO
FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FOUR EIGHT EIGHT
COSTA SUSPENSE AB FIVE FORTY
FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS ON ELDERLY CARE-
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION. AND WILL GO TO
FORTY TWO OR THREE FOR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY THERE'S NOBODY HERE
WILL GO TO TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE. MINORIES RUNNING
ONE ON THE PHONE LINE SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE FORTY. PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR AB
FIVE FORTY SUPPORT. ONE FILED
BY ZERO AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR JERRY MEMORY
BECAUSE WHEN PEOPLE ARE NOT BE
HAPPY WELL THE HEALTH AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND A FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB. FIVE
FOUR ZERO. AND WE HAVE NOBODY
ELSE QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO
TO OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE FORTY
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NO MEAN TWENTY FORTY.
MINORS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED AB. FIVE FORTY. I
TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR AB FIVE
FOUR ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION FOR AB FIVE FOUR
ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
WE HAVE NOBODY QUEUEING UP. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WILL GO TO PARTMINER
FINANCE. IF I AM STRUCTURE- NO
FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIVE FORTY BOS'S
SUSPENSE REMOVING ON THE AB
FIVE NINETY TWO BY SIMPLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN ON FOSTER YOUTH
HOUSING SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
OFFERS WAY PRESENTATION OVER
TESTIMONY SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWENTY
FORTY. NINERS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
NINE TWO. EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A
BI FIVE NINE TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FILED
BY ZERO AND WE ARE GOING TO GO
TO WINE. WHAT ONE MOMENT THERE
WITH THE OPERATOR STILL. FOR
BEARING WITH THIS WILL GO AWAY
ONE CAN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MEAN
WE WILL BE HAPPY CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY HEALTH
AGENCY REPORT RIGHT. FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR SUPPORT ON
AB FIVE NINE TWO. N. NO OTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT WHAT
OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE NINETY
TWO. NOBODY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY
IN TWENTY FORTY MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB FIVE NINE TWO. TO
OPPOSITION FOR EIGHTY FIVE NINE
TWO. PLEASE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY PRESS ONE ZERO.
FIRST OPPOSITION FOR AB FIVE
NINE TWO. NOBODY IS QUEUING UP
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT WITH
CHECK IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
MODERATOR TO ACTUALLY ME-
DEPARTMENT FINANCE YOU HAVE A
FILE THE FAMILY STRUCTURE NO
FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIVE NINETY TWO
GOES TO SUSPENSE MOVIE BABY SIX
OH FOUR BY MR DAILY ON ROAD
MAINTENANCE AND REHABILITATION
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION SO
RIGHT PUBLIC TESTIMONY THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM AND SUPPORT
THE FAMILY ROOM FORTY TWENTY
FORTY IN SPORT. MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX OH FOUR.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. I CAN SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI SIX ZERO FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ONE ZERO
FOR SUPPORT. FOR A BI SEXUAL
FOR. PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUING
UP. MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP FOR A BI SIX OH FOR
ALL RIGHT WE'VE DONE AB SIX OH
FOUR SUPPORT WILL GO NOW TO
OPPOSITION NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB. SIX OH FOUR. SO
OPPOSITION FOR A BI SEXUAL FOR
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. NO PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'VE DONE
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WE GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MR SHARE THIS BILL
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATES ARE
AMARI INTEREST APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
TO CALTRANS. I HAVE
HISTORICALLY NOT BEEN
STATUTORILY DIRECTED TO ANY
SPECIFIC PURPOSE HOWEVER THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT AS
APPROPRIATE THESE REVENUES
INCLUDING THREE HUNDRED SIXTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN ACCUMULATED
INTEREST AS WELL AS SEVEN
HUNDRED FOURTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN INTEREST OR TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT. TO THE STATE
HIGHWAY OPERATION AND
PROTECTION PROGRAM. BECAUSE
THIS BILL PROVIDES THE FUNDING
THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
APPROPRIATED AND BEYOND TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT ELIMINATES FUTURE
BUDGETARY FLEXIBILITY. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
SEEING THEIR QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB SIX OH FOUR WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE WE HAVE DONE AB
FOURTEEN NINETY NINE AND AB
FIFTEEN ELEVEN. AND SO WE WILL
MOVE. DIRECTLY TO A V. SIX TO
EIGHT BY EDUARDO GARCIA ON
BREAKING BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
HE'S WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENTED
SUPPORT THERE'S NO MINIMUM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MOTORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX TO EIGHT.
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI SIX TO
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND NO
PUBLIC COMMENT IS QUEUING UP.
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT OPPOSITION OF
AB SIXTY WAIT THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. THERE'S IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB SIX TO EIGHT. PRESS
OPPOSITION FOR AB SIX TO EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE ZERO. BUT OPPOSITION
TO AB SIX TO EIGHT. NOBODY IS
GOING UP ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE HAVE
A FILE AND FILES YOU SHARE NO
FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIX TO EIGHT WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON A. B.
SIX FIVE THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON ON MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS SUPPORT. OF AB
SIX FIVE THREE THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THIS COMPANY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX FIVE THREE.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
FIVE THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE ONE OH THREE ANYBODY
ELSE INTERESTED IN SUPPORT FOR
A BI SIX BY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. ONE OH THREE YOUR
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS MADELINE COOPER WITH
NIELSEN MARKSMAN BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN THE
COURT THANK YOU. ONE TEN YOU
ARE NOT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
IN MY APOLOGIES WHEN THE
CORRECTION EARLIER- MY SUPPORT
FOR. MY SUPPORT COMING WAS
ACTUALLY. FOR EIGHTY FIVE
FORTY. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
KNOW WHETHER PARTICIPANTS ARE
QUEUED UP MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF
AB SIX FIVE THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT THE
CAMINO OPPOSED TO AB SIX FIVE
THREE. YOU ARE OPPOSED TO AB
SIX BY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. N. PUBLIC
COMMENTERS QUEUING UP. WE HAVE
NO PARTICIPANTS ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF
AB SIX FIVE THREE MODERATE-
FINANCED YOU HAVE A- FILE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YES WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE IT WILL RESULT IN
INCREASED COST PRESSURES TO THE
GENERAL FUND. ARE NOT CURRENTLY
INCLUDED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S SPENDING PLAN
THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS ESTIMATES
COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN THE FIRST YEAR.
OF DECLINING TO ABOUT FOUR
NINETY THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN EACH SUBSEQUENT YEAR
THE GRANT PROGRAM FOR A TOTAL
COST OF ABOUT ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS. ADDITIONALLY
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COST OF NINE HUNDRED
SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
THE LEGAL SERVICES REVOLVING
FUND IN THE FIRST YEAR.
INCREASING TO ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THROUGH TWENTY THIRTY THIRTY
ONE DECLINING TO NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
THIRTY ONE THIRTY TWO.
ASSOCIATED WITH AN INCREASE IN
LITIGATION. I WOULD NOTE THAT
ANY REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WILL BE EVALUATED AS
PART OF THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM FINANCE WE HAVE NO%
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SIX FIVE THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. WILL MOVE ON TO AB
SEVEN THIRTEEN BY CRISTINA
GARCIA ASSEMBLY MEMBER THIS IS
ON STATE AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
SCOPING PLANET FOR SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION. AND WE'LL GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN THIRTEEN
SEE NOBODY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY
IN TWENTY FORTY- AND MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE. IN
SUPPORT. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVEN ONE THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
BILL PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUED UP.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
OF AB SEVEN THIRTEEN THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED AB. SEVEN
THIRTEEN. YOU ARE OPPOSED TO AB
SEVEN THIRTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND NOW AND
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP MISTER
CHAIR. I THAT WAS THAT WAS
OPPOSITION RIGHT. YES THAT WAS
OPPOSITION EIGHTY SEVEN
THIRTEEN AND ALL BUT HE DID
QUEUE UP ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
TO FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THEIR RESOURCES BOARD
ESTIMATES THIS BILL REQUIRES
THREE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE COST
OF IMPLEMENTATION I COUNTED
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
TWO HUNDRED NINETY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND ONE
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
AND I'M GOING. THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH ESTIMATES THE
BILL REQUIRES SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN FOUR POSITIONS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE. AND SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
TWENTY FOUR TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE HEALTH
ANALYSIS. WE WOULD NOTE THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
HELPED ACTUAL RESEARCH NEEDS
MAYBE LESS. GIVEN THE RESOURCES
FOR ME HE'S A CONTRACTOR FOR
SOME OF THIS WORK. FINALLY THE
OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
HAZARD ASSESSMENT ESTIMATES THE
BILL REQUIRES FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND I'M CALLING. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT HEARD FROM FINANCING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
SEVEN THIRTEEN. ABOUT A
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US. ON HIGHER
EDUCATION LABOR RELATIONS THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION OF A
RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY OF
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE THE SO MANY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATE
HEARING ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN FIFTY.
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR A BI
FIFTEEN FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND ONE
MOMENT WE DO HAVE A PARTICIPANT
WITH AN OPERATOR. ANYBODY ELSE-
PLEASE TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY IS
TO SOCIAL SUPPORT FOR A BI
FIFTEEN FIFTY BY HITTING ONE
ZERO AND LINE ONE TWENTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO QUERY
WOULD BE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES CALLING IN SUPPORT.
AND THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
WITHOUT OPPOSITION OF AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY. THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATES
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB FIFTEEN FIFTY. TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP OUR I WOULD
TRANSPORT OPPOSITION FINANCIER
OF THE FILE. FINANCE CHAIR NO
FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
COSTA SUSPENSE LIVING ON A. B.
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY ON STATE
PROPERTY TRANSFERS TO SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE NO- PRESENTATION AND
WE'LL GO RIGHT TO A- ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE FOR SUPPORT
NOBODY'S HERE. NOBODY'S IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN. YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN PLEASE. PRESS ONE ZERO
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
HAVE NO PARTICIPANT QUEUING UP
ALL RIGHT WELL GOOD OPPOSITION
OF AB SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN THIS
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OF THE IN
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN.
ID LIKE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
TO AB SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
WE HAVE NOBODY QUEUEING UP
NOBODY OPPOSED- FINANCIER FILE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YES WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE AS
A RESULT IN UNBUDGETED ONE TIME
COSTS TO THE GENERAL FUND IN
EXCESS OF SEVEN POINT NINE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL IS PREMATURE. TAKE IN
THE PROCESS TO DECLARE THIS
PROPERTY AS SURPLUS IN
ACCORDANCE WITH EXISTING LAW.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE HEARD FOR
FINANCE WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN A BE SEVEN
EIGHTY THREE BY GRAY AND EIGHTY
EIGHT OH THREE FIVE
BOERNER HORVATH HAS BEEN
PULLED. SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO- CV
THIRTEEN NINETY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH ON STATE
LAND SCHOOL IN N. LU PLANS.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION OF
A RIGHT TO SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY HERE. SEVEN IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MARTYRS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN NINETY. YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN NINETY
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. WE HAVE
NOBODY QUEUEING UP SIR ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO OPPOSITION
INNOVATORS ARE DEAD I APOLOGIZE
JUST QUEUED UP AT THE LAST
SECOND THERE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
PETER WAS A FAIR WITH OPERATOR
AND LINE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON JENNIFER
GONZALEZ CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE OFFICE OF THE TURN THE
GOVERNOR OF ANY COLLECTORS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN
NINETY THANK YOU. THE WEATHER
PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUED UP
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN
NINETY THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM. THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB
THIRTEEN NINETY. YOUR OPPOSED
AB THIRTEEN NINETY PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. NOBODY IS QUEUING UP
MISTER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION AND
THE CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM INDICATE THAT
THE BILL HAVE NO FISCAL IMPACT
OF WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE BILL
COULD INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
CONVEYANCE FRIENDS ACTIONS
SINCE THE BILL IS INTENDED TO
FACILITATE FASTER APPROVALS OF
SUCH TRANSACTIONS. THE BILL
ADDITION. 5% CAP ON REAL ESTATE
TRANSACTION FEES AND OTHER
ACQUISITION COSTS WHICH IN TURN
COULD INCREASE TOTAL COSTS TO
SCHOOL AND THEN. FIND OUT WE
WOULD ISSUE A NOTE THAT THE
FUND DOES HAVE SUFFICIENT
BALANCE TO ABSORB POTENTIAL
INCREASED COSTS. AND A
CONVEYANCE TRANSACTIONS COULD
ALSO INCREASE REVENUES TO THE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT FUND THANK
YOU. ARE HAVING HEARD FROM
SUPPORT OPPOSITION IN FINANCE
AND SENIOR QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB THIRTEEN NINETY
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. LIVING ON
THE AB EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE ON
MOBILE SLAUGHTER OPERATIONS.
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION. AND WILL GO TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY THERE'S NOBODY
EVER FORTY TWO OH THREE THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE. THE OF AB. EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT. SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FILED
BY ZERO FOR A. B. EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT. NOBODY IS KILLING UP-
SKEWS ME WE DO HAVE ONE QUEUING
UP ONE MOMENT THE OPERATOR GETS
ON THE LINE NUMBER. AND LINE
ONE TWENTY FIVE EUROPE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IF YOU SEE THAT ARE
CALIFORNIA CERTIFIED ORGANIC
FARMERS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS CUED UP
DISTRICT ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT THERE'S NOBODY HERE THIS
COMING ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
OPPOSED TO AB EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT. TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
AB EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. NOBODY IS GOING
UP MISTER CHAIR IWOULD CHECK
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION WE GO
TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE WOULD KNOW THAT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE- ESTIMATE
THE COST TO IMPLEMENT THIS BILL.
EIGHT HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND
SEVEN HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. AND I'M
GOING AS WELL AS FIVE NEW
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT PROGRAM
AND FORCE MEANT. OF THE BILL
DOES PROVIDE VIA FORTY. HOWEVER
THE DEPARTMENT KNOWS THAT THESE
COSTS WOULD LIKELY PUSH THE
FEES HIGH ENOUGH TO BE
EXORBITANT POTENTIALLY COST
PROHIBITIVE. THANK YOU- FOR
FINANCE WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT COSTA SAYS. WORDY
DE WITH. AB EIGHT NINETY SO
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON THE A.
B. ELEVEN OH SIX BY FAMILY
MEMBERS BRONTE'S ON EMPLOYMENT.
TRAINING PANEL SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION. WITH OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM DISCOVERED IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
OH SIX- TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB
ONE ONE ZERO SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. I KNOW
PUBLIC COMMENT A THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION OF AB ELEVEN OH
SIX THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
IS OPENING TWENTY FORTY. MINORS
ORANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB ELEVEN OH SIX. YOUR
POST AB ONE ONE ZERO SIX THE
FIRST ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NOBODY IS GIVING UP. ALL RIGHT
BERMAN FINANCE YOU HAVE A FILE.
HERE NO FILE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB ELEVEN OH
SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. WILL
GO TO AB FOURTEEN FORTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SURVIVED A SOUND
EMERGENCY SERVICES. GOT HIS WAY
PRESENTATION IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT SUPPORTERS
NOBODY REPORTED TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN FORTY ONE. SO SUPPORT
FOR A BI FOURTEEN FORTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
NOBODY IS KILLING UP. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF AB
FOURTEEN FORTY ONE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE
SOMEBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATE HEARING ON THE PHONE
LINE. OPPOSED AB FOURTEEN FORTY
ONE. PLEASE EXPRESS- OPPOSITION
TO AB FOURTEEN FORTY ONE BY
PRESSING ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONE ZERO. NOBODY IS QUEUING UP
ALL RIGHT WE TAKE IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION OF AB FOURTEEN
FORTY ONE FINANCING OF A FILE.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE IT WILL RESULT IN
GENERAL FUND COSTS AND COST
PRESSURES NOT INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT.
FURTHER WE WOULD NOTE THAT
CALLIE EST IS NOT HAVE THE
NECESSARY SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTISE TO ADVISE COUNTIES ON
YOUR NATAL CARE. FINALLY WE
KNOW THAT THIS BILL MAY CREATE
STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'VE HEARD
FOR FINANCE THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
FOURTEEN FORTY ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. WILL MOVE ON TO AB
ONE THOUSAND NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM ON FARM TO
SCHOOL FOOD HAVE PROGRAMS THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL RIGHTS PUBLIC
COMMENT. THERE'S NOBODY
REPORTED TWO OR THREE IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MINORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE. IN SUPPORT
OF AB ONE THOUSAND NINE. SHOW
SUPPORT FOR AB ONE ZERO ZERO
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. FOR
AB ONE ZERO ZERO NINE. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY SIX FOR
ANYBODY ELSE EXPRESSING SUPPORT
FOR A BI TEN OH NINE THIS PRESS
ONE ZERO TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND SENATORS CATHOLIC GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION IN
PROUD SUPPORT AB ONE THOUSAND
NINE. THANK YOU KNOW OTHER
PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUED UP
MISTER SHARP I WOULD OPPOSITION
OF AB ONE THOUSAND NINE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED AB ONE THOUSAND
NINE. EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR AB
ONE ZERO ZERO NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. NOBODY IS KILLING UP
MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN THE FULL SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE HAVE A FILE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YES WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE IT RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES OF OVER ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS INITIALLY
GOING TO THAT THREE MILLION TO
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS. THAT
ARE NOT CURRENTLY INCLUDED IN
THE BUDGET PLAN IN ADDITION
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES A NEW
PROGRAM AND ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
SB LARGELY DIFFICULT. IN
PROGRAMS AND AD HOC ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THANK YOU REGARD FOR
FINANCE WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB ONE
THOUSAND NINE GOES TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE MAYBE TEN TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLOOR ON
CONTRACTORS AND SUBCONTRACTORS
OF SUSPENSE CANADA AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION OF ALL RIGHT
PUBLIC TESTIMONY THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE SUPPORT OF A BABY
TEN TWENTY THREE. YOUR SUPPORT
OF AB TEN TWENTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE ZERO IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN TWENTY
THREE. PLEASE QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT WITHOUT
OPPOSITION OF AB TEN TWENTY
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY. NINERS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB TEN
TWENTY THREE. AND IT IT'S YOUR
TURN TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR A.
B. TEN TWENTY THREE BY PRESSING
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
NOBODY'S GOING UP MISTER CHAIR.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
AND THEN OPPOSITION FINANCE
HAVE A FILE. THE FILE- FILE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TEN TWENTY THREE GOES TO
SUSPENSE. AB ELEVEN OH THREE BY
MEGAN DOLLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON
AGRICULTURAL LANDS THIS IS A
STRANGE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION OF A RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY HERE IS HOW MANY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN OH THREE.
TO SUPPORT FOR A BI ELEVEN OH
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. OR AB. ELEVEN OH
THREE. I'M GETTING NOBODY
QUEUEING UP AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN THE SUPPORT
LET'S CUT OPPOSITION FOR A. B.
ELEVEN OH THREE. NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM NOBODY IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
MODERATOR ANYONE OPPOSED AB
ELEVEN OH THREE. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN OH
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NOBODY QUEUEING UP.
R. I. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HAVE A FILE. THANK YOU MISTER
SHARE YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT RESULTS
IN GENERAL FUND COSTS AND COST
PRESSURES NOT INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET.
ADDITIONALLY THERE ARE CONCERNS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION. MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO MEET CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS IN THE BILL.
ACCESS TO SPECIFY DATA. WE NOTE
THAT CAL FIRE ESTIMATES THE
BILL COULD COST. APPROXIMATELY
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR THE
FIRST YEAR. AND ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND THEREAFTER. THANK
MUCH WE HAVE NO QUESTION SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. A. B. ELEVEN
OH THREE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON AB TWELVE NINETEEN
MAR ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN ON
HERITAGE PRESERVATION TAX
CREDIT. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OPPOSITE WAY
PRESENTATION WITH OUR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM. FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
NINETEEN. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWELVE NINETEEN IT'S YOUR
TURN PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
FOR SUPPORT FOR A BI ONE TWO
ONE NINE. AND WE HAVE O
PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP. ALL
RIGHT WITHOUT OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THAT HAVE BEEN TWENTY FORTY
MODERATE ANYONE OPPOSED AB
TWELVE NINETEEN. PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO IF YOU ARE
PROPOSED TO AB ONE TWO ONE NINE.
AND I'M GETTING NOBODY QUEUEING
UP AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE HAVE A FILE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD STATES THE
REVENUE IMPACT RELATED TO TAX
CREDITS CLAIMED IS CURRENTLY
UNKNOWN DUE TO THE DIFFICULTY
IN ESTIMATING THE NUMBER AND
AMOUNT OF DONATIONS. WE WOULD
KNOW THAT WHILE THE GENERAL
FUND IS REIMBURSED FOR THE COST.
CLAIMED ELIGIBLE BOND FUNDS
THAT CAN BE REDIRECTED AND USED
TO REIMBURSE THE GENERAL FUND
ARE ULTIMATELY REPAID WITH
GENERAL FUND AND THEREFORE THIS
PROGRAM COULD STILL CREATE COST
PRESSURES TO THE STATE. FINALLY
AT THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AND
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
STATE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
WOULD BE MINOR AND CIRCLE. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE HEARD FOR FINANCE
WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS ABOUT
OBJECTION. AB TWELVE NINETEEN
WITH A SUSPENSE MOVIE ON A. B.
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE UNSUPERVISED PERSON
RELEASE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION. AND WE WILL- GO
TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY TO SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT. YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. WE HAVE NO PARTICIPANT
QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT THAT'S GOOD
OPPOSITION OF TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT. THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT WHICH
MEANS OPPOSED AB TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT. TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
AB TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND NOBODY IS
KILLING UP MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT WITH TEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE SEVEN FIVE.
YOU FILE. A FILE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVIE ON AB TWELVE
THIRTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TING ON PEDESTRIAN ACCESS TO
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION. OVER PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TO PORTEN FORTY TWO
OR THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE
AND INCOME IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATE OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE THAT IS SUPPORT
OF AB. TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT. AT
THIS TIME IF YOU ARE I SUPPORT
OF AB TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE ZERO
IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
TWO THREE EIGHT. AND WE DO HAVE
A PARTICIPANT. ONE MOMENT
MISTER SHARE THERE WAS AN
OPERATOR. AND WE WOULD ONLY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BENEFACTOR BEGINNING A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
AND THE FINAL REMINDER IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE TWO
THREE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. NOBODY ELSE WAS QUEUING
UP. ALL RIGHT WE'RE OPPOSITION
OF AB TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT
NOBODY'S IN THIS ROOM. NOBODY
IN TWENTY FORTY MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB. TWELVE THIRTY
EIGHT. YOU ARE NOT POSITION TO
AB TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
YEAH WE DO HAVE ONE KILLING UP
ACTUALLY A COUPLE PLEASE BEAR
WITH THIS PICTURE. AT OUR FIRST
PURCHASE BUT IF ONE ONE TWENTY
NINE YOU ARE OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS CARLOS I LIVE IN- SENATOR
HENRY STERN'S DISTRICT AND I'M
CALLING- IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE.
TWO THREE EIGHT- ALONG WITH
CALIFORNIA WALKS IN ST FOR ALL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE- ONE
TWENTY YOU ARE OPEN. YEAH
OPPOSITION. I DON'T THINK THE
CURRICULUMS READY YET. WE HAVE
NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE HAVE A FILE. THIS IS
YOUR SHARE ARE WE ESTIMATE THE
STILL IS UNLIKELY TO RESULT IN
AN UNKNOWN DECREASE AND FIND
REVENUE- THAT WOULD AFFECT BOTH
STATE AND LOCAL REVENUES.
ADDITION TROLL SITES MINOR
OBSERVABLE COSTS A SERVICES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
REPORTING REQUIRED IN THE STILL.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE HEARD FROM
FINANCE WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWELVE
THIRTY WILL GO TO SENSE MOVING
ON AB TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN RIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON ON
SMALL TELEPHONE CORPORATIONS.
THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE OFFERS
WAY PRESENTATION AND WE WILL-
GO TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ND
NOBODY IS KILLING UP. ALL RIGHT
WATER OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE
FIFTY SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THE FAMILY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATION ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN. PLEASE
EXTRA- PLEASE EXPRESS
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME FOR AB
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN BY PRESSING
ONE ZERO. NOBODY IS KILLING UP
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT FINANCE HAVE A FILE.
THE FILE NO FILE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION CITY TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE OUR FINAL BILL IS AB
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYERON BAIL
PREMIUMS TO SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION SO
RIGHT PUBLIC TESTIMONY CAN
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN. TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT FOR A BI THIRTEEN
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF
AB THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IS OPEN
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR'S
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN.
YOU ARE OPPOSED TO AB THIRTEEN
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. RESEARCHER THERE'S NO
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME
RIGHT NOW OPPOSITION NO SUPPORT
WILL GO TO FARMING TO FINANCE.
A FOUNDATION- FILE NO QUESTIONS
ABOUT OBJECTION AB THIRTEEN
FORTY SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
THERE ARE NO BILLS ON CALL- SO
WE'VE DONE ALL OF OUR- BILLS
THAT WERE DO PASSES WE'VE DONE
ALL OF OUR SUSPENSE BILLS. SO I
WILL SAY THANK YOU TO EVERYONE
WHO PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY. IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
CHRISTIAN GESTIONES IN WRITING
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY AND
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU ONLY PRETTY PROFICIENT
EVERYONE'S PARTICIPATION. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE'VE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA. AND THIS APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING IS ADJOURNED.